So, ich bin auf jeden Fall on fire, richtig bock jetzt. Gut, wir starten. Ah nee, sollt ihr noch Licht anmachen, das wäre noch eine Idee, gell? Guck mal, auf einmal bin ich hell. So, wir blicken auf die Serie A, die Premier League und La Liga. Es ist mal wieder Zeit für die Ligatour Europa mit Uli Hebel, Christian Bernhardt und Fabian Pakulat. Und genau jetzt geht es los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und ich freue mich sehr, meine Runde hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Servus Jungs.
Guten Morgen.
Bernie, du musst beginnen. Wie war es in Mailand?
Ja, sehr schön. Sehr beeindruckend, diesen Fußball-Tempel. Ich glaube, darauf können wir uns einigen. Von innen zu leben, und zwar besonders beeindruckend, ist unten am Spielfeldrand einfach. Also wir haben kurz vor Spielbeginn unten noch gedreht und dann während der Aufnahme hat plötzlich die Kurva Sud von Milan unvermittelt angefangen zu singen.
Haben sie dich endlich erkannt, Stahl?
Genau. Auf jeden Fall. Das war so laut da unten. Also wirklich beeindruckend. Wenn man das von unten erlebt, ist das nochmal was dafür eine Wucht sozusagen für eine Emotionalität und so entsteht. Also ja, war sehr, sehr speziell. Also wirklich ein tolles Erlebnis, so eine Derby-Atmosphäre, dann wirklich auch im Inneren und ganz nah dran erleben zu dürfen.
Und verändert das die Art und Weise, wie man über so ein Spiel berichtet?
Also ich sage mal so, also wie man übers Spielbild, ich meine, das kann Uli ja auch aus längerer Erfahrung schon sagen. Was logisch ein Riesenunterschied ist, ist einfach, man hat die Totale des Feldes. Also das macht logischerweise beim Kommentieren. Wir haben ja sonst normalerweise aus der Kabine auch nur den Bildausschnitt. Und wenn du aber neben dir den Bildschirm hast und unten siehst du das ganze Feld und kannst halt alles auch beobachten, das macht einen Riesenunterschied, finde ich gerade so im Analysieren aus. Also da siehst du Sachen, die du halt aus dem Bildausschnitt gar nicht erleben kannst. Und ja, ich weiß schon, was du meinst, Max. Diese Emotionalität, würde ich schon sagen, die überträgt sich auch ein bisschen auf den Kommentar. Weil das, klar kommt es am Fernsehen schon gut rüber, aber in so einem Kessel drin ist das halt nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer. Also ja, macht schon was mit einem, definitiv.
Und es stellt einen auch für Rasenfunk-Aufnahmen. Wir haben es einem mal wieder vorherrschenden Streik zu verdanken, dass du auch jetzt mit der ganzen Wucht von, sagen wir mal, ZuschauerInnen diese Sendung hier aufmachen wirst. Aber das stört uns gar nicht. Der Rasenfunk war immer schon ein kinderfreundlicher Podcast. Und wir sind auch streiksolidarisch, Leute. Bessere Löhne für alle, für alle, die in diesen Berufen arbeiten. Bitte, bitte, bitte. Wir haben jetzt vorhin nicht drüber geredet. Wir gehen gleich in eure Themen rein. Ist von euch bei der Champions League aus dem Achtelfinale jetzt, sind da irgendwelche wichtigen Dinge hängen geblieben, was man irgendwie kurz ansprechen müsste? Uli, gibt es irgendwas? Also, Premier League hatte ein fürchterliches erste Lack. Also, Hinspielserie, jetzt Rückserie. Hat dich da noch irgendwas überrascht?
Die Deutlichkeit bei Newcastle wahrscheinlich war schon überraschend. Ja, wobei. Also ja, die Deutlichkeit schon. Also, dass sie rausgehen würden, das war mir schon klar. Weil, wenn da hätten sie es, glaube ich, im ersten Spiel machen müssen, da waren sie echt gut. Und es war wahrscheinlich die beste Saisonleistung sogar. Aber, und Chelsea war deutlich knapper, als es das Ergebnis meint, glaube ich. Und der Rest ist aber, glaube ich, so in Ordnung, wie es war. Ja, ich glaube, der Rest spiegelt ganz gut wieder, was ist im Moment.
Ja, gut, dass City, also Guardiola gegen Real rausgeht. Auch daran haben wir uns jetzt ja inzwischen gewöhnt. Fabian?
Ja, und es sind auch genau die Probleme, die es bei City einfach gibt, sind auch da gezeigt worden.
Exakt. Fabian, wie ist es mit Spanien?
Ja, ich glaube, bei Real Madrid, da wollen wir ja nachher noch ein bisschen drauf schauen, die sind einfach Königsklassen-Könige. Obwohl es in der Liga nicht so läuft haben, sind der Königsklasse wieder unglaublich performt. Gegen City, also Guardiola, weiß ich nicht, der hat Albträume von Real Madrid, glaube ich. Inzwischen ist es ja wirklich krass, wie sie immer wieder diese Spiele dominieren können. Natürlich hatten sie dann auch immer Glück in verschiedenen Phasen und so weiter, aber es ist wirklich Real Madrid und Königsklasse, das ist wie gesagt Topf auf Deckel. Deckel auf Topf, natürlich. Und Atletico Madrid, glaube ich, hatte ein bisschen Glück mit der Auslösung, denn Tottenham ist ja wild und da kann man schon mal gewinnen. Atletico Madrid ist auch nicht so stabil, würde ich sagen, aber gegen Tottenham hat es dann natürlich gereicht und Barca war sehr deutlich gegen Newcastle, vielleicht zu deutlich nach dem Hinspiel, aber wenn es bei denen halt mal vorne läuft, dann geht es halt wie bei den Bayern auch mal schnell über die 5 Tore. Und ja, dementsprechend ist es kein großes, glaube ich, Verwundernis, dass die drei spanischen Top-Klubs mal wieder in einem Viertelfinale stehen. Aber wie gesagt, Atletico hatte, glaube ich, ein gutes Losglück und real ist einfach real.
Das ist schon wirklich erstaunlich, dass wir hier nach einem Achtelfinale mit historisch vielen Toren alle so völlig abgeklärt dasitzen. Das sagt auch ein bisschen was über den europäischen Fußball aus, muss man sagen. Die einzigen, die so wirklich enttäuscht haben, sind die italienischen Teams, auch Atalanta. Da haben wir noch alle heiß gemacht und haben ihnen erzählt, was Atalanta so kann. Und dann werden sie schon im Hinspiel so weggebügelt vom FC Bayern. Ist das jetzt außer der Reihe oder muss man da halt auch sagen, ja gut, es lief halt dann auch. Also wenn du nach 25 Minuten mit 3 zu 0 führst, aufwärts, auswärts, also was soll dann noch kommen? Dann ist es auch wirklich schwer.
Ja, würde ich schon sagen. Also klar, Atalanta, es wurde ja viel im Hinspiel über die Taktik geredet, weil eben Balladino weg von seiner Dreierkette ist auf dieses 4-4-2, was die Mannschaft nicht kennt. Ich finde, das wurde ein bisschen zu groß gemacht, denn das erste Gegentor ist ein Standard. Da ist, glaube ich, relativ egal, ob du Dreierkette oder Viererkette und sie pennen. Das Zweite ist auch dieser Elysée-Move. Ich glaube, den macht er mit Viererkette auch. Also, und dann kommst du halt in so einen negativen Ding an. Und ich fand, die Bayern, muss ich wirklich sagen, im Hinspiel, das war schon allererste Sahne. Also, und dann hat er ja in der Halbzeit umgestellt. Und dann kriegen sie mit Viererkette auch noch drei Stück. Also, ich fand, das war wirklich ein bisschen, wenn die Bayern in so einer Prime sind, wie sie da gerade waren. Also klar hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass Atalanta daheim sechs Stück kriegt, keine Frage. Aber ich glaube, das hatte schon viel mit der Stärke der Bayern zu tun. Und wir hatten ja glaube ich, Bayern Atalanta haben halt auch noch im Hinspiel Ederson, de Ketelare, Raspadore gefehlt. Das war ja gegen Dortmund gar kein Thema. Aber irgendwann ist es halt auch ein, ja, wie sagt man, Qualitätsunterschied, wenn dir gewisse Spieler als kleineren Verein, glaube ich, fehlen. Dann fängst du die halt gegen die Top-Top-Top-Clubs jetzt nicht unbedingt auf. Ich würde sagen, es hatte viel mit der Stärke der Bayern zu tun, dass Atalanta jetzt so eine schlechte Figur gemacht hat. Aber da ich ja nicht so viel aus italienischer Sicht beisteuern konnte, ich muss schon trotzdem sagen, ich fand die Spanier trotzdem beeindruckend. Wenn wir ja oft hier auch hören, dass in der Liga in Spanien, ja, es gibt Probleme und so, aber dass du dann international so auftrittst. Und ja, ich bin bei euch klar, Tottenheim ist im Moment nicht wirklich ein Champions-League-Standard. Aber dass sie jetzt Pfassa und Real da, City und Newcastle teilweise auseinandernehmen oder so sicherschlagen, finde ich, muss man dann schon mal hervorheben, dass das dann schon auch für die Spanier dann spricht. Dass sie da so einen Weg durchgehen und dann einfach gemütlich mit 3 Mann im Viertelfinale stehen. Also das ist mir schon hängen geblieben, muss ich sagen.
Bisschen schade, dass jetzt Barca und Atletico aufeinandertreffen. Aber so ist es eben ab einer gewissen Runde. Also wäre ja jetzt auch schon möglich gewesen. Aber dann Christian, dann bleiben wir jetzt bei dir. Und der Blick von der Champions League zu Como, der ist tatsächlich ein Kürzer, denn die liegen aktuell auf einem Champions League-Platz auf Rang 4. Cesc Fabregas kocht und alle reiben sich jetzt schon die Hände. Wo wird er irgendwann mal hinwechseln? Die Frage ist, ob er überhaupt irgendwo hinwechseln muss, wenn er mit Como ja schon solche Erfolge feiern kann. Also was zeichnet denn Como aus und wie sieht denn seine Perspektive da aus?
Ja, jetzt müssen wir wirklich mal ein bisschen tiefer draufschauen. Ich meine, das Thema Como hatten wir ja schon. Aber jetzt ist es wirklich, wir sind jetzt Ende März und Como ist im Moment eben 4. Also steht auf dem Champions League-Platz, hat am vergangenen Wochenende die Roma geschlagen, direkter Konkurrent, hat vor kurzem Juve geschlagen, direkter Konkurrent. Also ganz kurz, um es notabularisch einzufangen. Das spannendste Rennen in der Serie A ist im Moment, das um den letzten Champions League-Platz. Eben Como, Roma und Juve, die sind innerhalb von zwei oder drei Punkten. Und ja, im Moment hat Como die Nase vorn. Wie gesagt, am Wochenende Roma geschlagen. Und ja, jetzt sind sie wirklich ein heißer Kandidat, in dieser Saison in die Champions League einzuziehen. Und dementsprechend, ja, lohnt es sich, glaube ich, da mal drauf zu schauen. Wo fangen wir an? Ja, fangen wir bei Fabregas an. Ja, bitte. Das macht wahrscheinlich Sinn. Ja, also was auffällig ist, die halbe Liga legt sich mit ihm an, weil seine, ich sag mal so, jeder, glaube ich, der noch an den Spieler Fabregas denkt, hat ja das Elegante im Sinn, eben dieses, ja, diese spanische Leichtigkeit, dieses, hier bei Barca gespielt, bei Unterwenger, bei Arsenal, bei Chelsea, so diese, sag ich mal, spanische Grandezza. Und jetzt ist es schon auffällig, dass es auch geschafft hat Como, wir kommen ja auch gleich drauf zu reden, klar ist Como auch eine sehr spanische Mannschaft, sag ich mal, die logischerweise so gar nicht unbedingt in die Serie A reinpasst. Aber was auffällig ist, es sind alle Spiele mit Como, gerade gegen die direkten Konkurrenten, sehr heiß, sehr emotional. Jetzt gegen die Roma, zuletzt auch gegen andere große Italäner. Es gab danach immer heftige Diskussionen. Er ist jetzt mit Gasperini zusammengerasselt nach dem Roma-Spiel. Gasperini hat ihm angeblich nicht die Hand gegeben nach dem Spiel. Dann meinte Fabregas, so bin ich aber nicht erzogen worden. Nach jedem Spiel gebe ich dem gegnerischen Trainer die Hand, auch wenn ich verliere. Dann meinte Gasperini nur so, ich schätze Como sportlich sehr, aber ich bin nicht damit einverstanden, wie sie sich auch von lebendem Platz präsentieren. Das war nicht das erste Mal, weil Fabregas ist auch mit Allegri richtig heftig vor Kurzem nach dem Milan-Spiel. Da gab es heftige Diskussionen und das finde ich insofern spannend. Das zeigt logisch zum einen, bin ich mir ganz sicher, gerade von diesen großen italienischen Trainer-Namen, glaube ich, da schwingt ein gewisser Neid mit, weil Como einfach da jetzt mittendrin ist, weil Fabregas logischerweise diese Aura eines, ja, wie soll man sagen, jetzt schon Superstars hat, obwohl er ja noch gar nicht lange trainiert und weil er logischerweise ungefähr mehr oder weniger jeden Spieler bekommt, den er bisher wollte, weil Como halt einfach diese indonesischen, sehr finanzkräftigen Investoren hinter sich hat. Aber es zeigt auch, würde ich sagen, schon ein bisschen, dass Fabregas es geschafft hat, da nicht nur eine schöne, spielerische, schöne Fußballmannschaft hinzustehen, sondern Como kann schon auch eklig. Und das sind auch immer ein paar Szenen, gerade in den großen Spielen, die sehr diskussionsbedürftig sind. Und da sieht man vielleicht bei Fabregas auch den Einfluss. Wir hatten sie als Spieler, klar, und Guardiola beim großen Barca aller Zeiten, bei dieser Wundermannschaft, Barca mit Messi und Co., dann eben mit Arsenal, mit Wenger. Aber er war halt auch bei Chelsea und da hat er als Trainer Morini und konnte gehabt. Und ich glaube schon, dass er sich von allen eben so ein bisschen was mitgenommen hat und dass er verstanden hat, hier der große sympathische Verein zu sein, bringt jetzt, glaube ich, auf höchstem Niveau nicht immer unbedingt, weiß Gott, was Positives. Und deswegen hat das ihnen schon auch geschafft, Como so ein bisschen ja manchmal so eine eklige Note mitzugeben. Und dementsprechend ist Fabregas logisch in aller Munde. Und auf deine Frage, wie lange der noch da ist, ich glaube, das kann logisch nur er beantworten. Fakt ist, er ist ja nicht nur Trainer, er ist ja auch Anteilseigner an Como, also er hat ja auch Anteile. Und ich sage mal einfach so, ohne es logisch zu wissen, ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass er jetzt im Sommer schon geht, wenn er jetzt mit Como nächstes Jahr international spielen kann. Weil selbst, wenn es mit der Champions League nicht klappen sollte, würden sie ja Europa League oder Conference League spielen, weil da schaut es richtig gut aus. Und das ist jetzt nur ein Gefühl von mir. Ich glaube noch nicht, dass er schon den Sprung macht. Und ja, dementsprechend wird dieser Fabregas-Hype, würde ich erst mal weitergehen sagen.
Und es ist ja auch so, also ich weiß von einem Bundesligisten, weiß ich ganz sicher, dass er sich um Como bemüht hat und es wird berichtet, dass es noch ein zweiter auch war. Und damals hat er abgesagt. Offenbar hat er ja auch noch anderen Clubs abgesagt. Und was sollte sich zum Schlechteren verändert haben, wenn er jetzt quasi in der zweiten Saison genau so viel erfolgt hat?
Wer war der zweite?
Na dann verrate ich ja den ersten.
Na ja, also vielleicht weiß ich auch nur den ersten und nicht den zweiten.
Also wer hat denn alles so Trainer gesucht? Leverkusen hat Trainer gesucht, Wolfsburg hat Trainer gesucht, Leipzig hat Trainer gesucht, Borussia Dortmund hat die Kokovac. So und da waren jetzt zwei dabei.
Ja okay, okay. Ich check's.
Okay, sehr gut. Können wir danach ja auch nochmal besprechen?
Also es war doch nicht Heidenheim?
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Die waren, äh, da hat Frank Schmidt gesagt, er macht noch eine Saison, dann haben sie gesagt, gut, dann halt so.
Verständlich.
Er hat in Italien ja auch abgesackt, großen Clubs im Sommer. Also er hat mehrere Absagen verteilt im vergangenen Sommer, ja, definitiv.
Aber dann sag doch mal, also das eine ist quasi so, wie jetzt auf ihn reagiert wird und ich mein, das ist ja ein wichtiger Hinweis zu wissen, also Como, auch wenn man sich zum Beispiel die gelben Karten anguckt, 61 gelbe Karten, 3 rote Karten, also es gibt noch 3 Teams, die haben mehr in der Serie A, aber das ist schon relativ weit oben. Die sonstigen Statistiken, die deuten ja aber eher auf einen sehr guten Ballbesitzfußball hin, also Meisterballbesitz der Serie A, beste Passquote, eine der drittbeste Angriffe aktuell und auch die zweitbeste Defensive, was eben so Schüsse aufs eigene Tor angeht. Das heißt, alles, was ich so herauslese, und ich habe leider viel zu wenig von Como gesehen, um es selber beurteilen zu können, ist dominanter Ballbesitz und dadurch Spielkontrolle und deswegen auch wenig Gefahr fürs eigene Tor. Ist das so dein Stil?
Sehr gut, Max. Du hast hier eigentlich schon alles erledigt. Wie gesagt, wollen wir ja schon kurz darauf schauen, wie sie das eben machen. Und genau, du hast das Wichtigste schon zusammengefasst, deswegen meinte ich ein bisschen eine spanische Mannschaft, wahnsinnig dominant mit Ball, glaube ich mehr als 60 Prozent Ballbesitz mit Abstand der Meiste. Dann ein sehr, sehr intensives Pressing, also der PPDR-Wert, der ja die Intensität des Pressings misst. Das sind in ganz Europa von den Top-5-Ligen nur Barca und PSG haben einen etwas höheren Wert. Dann kommt schon Como auf Rang 3, also jetzt nicht, also sehr realogisch auf 1 und international auf Rang 3. Also viele hohe intensive Ballgewinne, um dann eben wieder diese Dominanz auszuspielen. Und wie du sagst eben, das ist besonders, er hat halt eine wunderbare Balance gefunden. Sie sind nicht nur offensiv stark, sondern auch defensiv. Also drittbester Angriff, zweitbester Defensive. Also es ist eine Mannschaft, die sich im Ballbesitz wohlfühlt, die über außen sehr gute 1 gegen 1 Spieler hat. Jesus Rodriguez, den Fabian sicherlich noch kennt, nur mal um da die Dimension einzuleiten. Den haben sie für 22 Millionen im Sommer geholt und der hat im Herbst für die spanische A-Nationalmannschaft debütiert. Also in Como spielten spanische A-Nationalmannschaftsspieler.
Er hatte nur eine gute Saison bei Betis. Er ist gerade erst rausgekommen aus der Jugend und ist sofort zu Como und alle dachten, hey, 22 Millionen, klappt das? Damals war er 19, glaube ich.
Ja, genau.
Gleich und so weiter, aber es hat anscheinend funktioniert.
Dass es ja dieser Weg, den Como eingeschlagen hat, sehr junge, talentierte Spieler zu kaufen, um die dann im Idealfall weiterzuentwickeln und irgendwann später für viel Geld zu verkaufen, das größte Beispiel ist logisch Niko Pass von Real, wo ja Real immer noch diese Recomprac-Klausel hat. Also die können den im Sommer für 9 oder 10 Millionen zurückholen und jetzt deutet auch einiges darauf hin, dass sie das im Sommer machen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie ihn für sich selbst brauchen, aber um ihn im Zweifel für 70 weiter zu verkaufen, weil ich weiß, dass im Winter hat der Como schon um die 70er-Angebote aus der Premier League verpasst. Also Real hat da logischerweise auch alles richtig gemacht, weil entweder du baust ihn selbst ein oder halt du machst wahnsinnig viel Geld draus oder du lässt ihn nochmal in die Einkommen, weil sie könnten 207 ihn auch wieder für eine geringe Summe zurückholen. Also da muss man schon auch sagen, das macht Real richtig clever. Jakubo Ramon, Innenverteidiger von der Real Jugend, genau dasselbe Prinzip, den hat Como für wenige Millionen bekommen. Aber da hat Real auch diese Rückkaufklausel. Den wollen jetzt auch schon sehr viele in Europa, also extrem beeindruckender Verteidiger, groß gewachsen. Der hat zum Beispiel, das war jetzt wunderschön zu sehen im Spiel gegen die Roma, Fabregas gegen Gasperini, also viel Mann gegen Mann, viel Intensität gegen den Ball, war wirklich ein sehr intensives Spiel. Und da hat Fabregas Ramon als Innenverteidiger immer wieder, um eben dieses 1 gegen 1 Pressing sozusagen vor Probleme zu stellen, immer wieder auf die vordeste Linie gezogen aus dem Spiel raus. Weil er als direkten Gegenspieler Wesley hatte, den brasilianischen Nationalspieler, und der hat ungefähr 20 Zentimeter weniger, sozusagen an Höhe mitzubringen. Und also wirklich total spannend, wie Fabregas das Ganze dann auch liest eben im Spiel. Und ja, dieser Ramon ist der Nächste, der wird ja in Kürze auch auf noch höherem Niveau spielen. Und genau, also viel Ballbesitz über außen, gutes 1 gegen 1. Trotzdem wahnsinnig vieles so Halbraumspieler. Im Nikko Bass hat man Baturina, den ich sicherlich auch noch einige kennen, von Dinamo Zagreb, der junge Kroate. Den haben sie auch im Sommer für 20 geholt. Der hat ein paar Monate Anlaufzeit gebraucht und jetzt aber seit zwei, drei Monaten dominiert der da. Da haben sie wirklich ein paar Spieler, die dann auch im Halbraum eben durchs Zentrum durch das Super bespielen können. Und Einnahmen müssen wir noch nennen. Lucas da Cunha, Franz Jose, der hat schon Serie B für Como gespielt, ist jetzt schon das dritte Jahr da. Und der ist vielleicht so ein bisschen das Symbolspieler dieses Fabregas-Fußballs. Der war früher ein Zehner und den hat er umfunktioniert jetzt für die Doppel-Sechs. Und das sagt ja alles. Also er will einfach spielstarke Spieler. Er will Spieler, die mit dem Ball was anfangen können. Und der letzte Mann, Duvikas, griechischer Stürmer, kam von Celta Vigo, den hatten noch nicht so viele auf dem Zettel. Der ist jetzt der zweiter erfolgreichste Torschütze in der Serie A. Also was ich damit sagen will, sie haben nicht nur die großen Namen oder diese riesen Talente, wie Jesus Rodriguez oder Baturina, ich glaube, da konnte man sich drauf verlassen, dass die viel Qualität mitbringen, sondern sie haben auch so einen bisschen kleineren Segment, gut gescoutet, was gut zu ihnen passt. Morata spielt zum Beispiel keine große Rolle sportlich, weil Duvikas eben diese Rolle wunderbar ausfüllt der Grieche. Und ja, jetzt hast du eine Mannschaft da, die jetzt schon in diesem Jahr um die Champions League-Plätze mitspielt. Und das sogar, finde ich, die letzten zwei Sätze dazu. In den letzten Wochen war Nico Paz gar nicht mehr mal so auffällig. Also, der war monatelang der Spieler, der die Mannschaft getragen hat. Aber jetzt zuletzt haben sie gewonnen, obwohl er wirklich seit ein paar Spielen gar nicht auffällig ist. Und vor allen Dingen haben sie jetzt gelernt, auch so dreckige Spiele zu gewinnen gegen die vermeintlich kleineren. Da haben sie in der Hinrunde oft noch 1-1 Punkte liegen lassen. Und jetzt gewinnen sie solche Spiele auch verlässlich. Also, sie sind ein sehr heißer Kandidat. Sie haben, glaube ich, auch vom Restkalender her auf dem Papier ein gutes Programm. Also, es ist wirklich alles andere als unrealistisch, dass sie es womöglich schaffen könnten, schon dieses Jahr in die Champions League einzuziehen.
Und das Ganze mit einem Investor hintendran. Also, das sind indonesische Milliardäre, wenn ich es jetzt gerade richtig gelesen habe, die auch so ein Multiclub-Ownership aufziehen, so wie es gerade alle machen. Also, daher kommt das Geld. Aber man muss sagen, bisher haben sie– also, du hast es ja schon quasi immer so ein bisschen mit erzählt. Also, sie haben jetzt nicht die 100 Millionen Transfers gemacht, sondern sie hatten halt dann das Kapital im unteren bis mittleren Millionenbereich eben zu investieren. Das steht dahinter.
Sie haben nicht die 100 Millionen Transfers einzeln gemacht, aber sie haben schon pro Transferperiode heftig hingelegt. Also gerade auch teilweise im Winter nochmal 50 hingelegt. Also es ist logischerweise, das muss man jetzt schon bei all dem Charme, den so, es ist ein kleinen Como am See, schöne Geschichte. Aber logischerweise ist da einfach eine Finanzkraft dahinter. Also dieses indonesische Brüderbar, da reden wir anscheinend geschätzt über 30 Milliarden Dollar Vermögen. Also die spielen wirklich, wenn die wollen, spielen die in der aller, aller, aller, allerhöchsten Liga mit. Und dementsprechend ist es logischerweise weiterhin, was Künstliches, vor allen Dingen ein Punkt dazu. Italienische Spieler, Einsatzminuten in dieser Saison bei Como 3. Und das ist kein Witz Ende März. Also es ist, ja, es ist logischerweise, es ist ein künstliches Konstrukt, gar keine Frage, ein sehr finanzkräftiges Konstrukt. Aber es ist vielleicht ein bisschen anders halt einfach von, von der Idee als vielleicht andere, ja, wie sagt man, ausländische, intensive, finanzkräftige Konstrukte, die wir bisher erlebt haben.
Ja und wie schlau es auch einfach, es ist dem Trainer Anteile am Club zu geben, womit er ein genuines Interesse daran hat, dass Como Erfolg hat, denn dann hat auch er Erfolg. Also es ist sehr interessant, sie sind auch im Frauenfußball investiert. Mercury 13 heißt da quasi das Konstrukt und da haben sie eben logischerweise die Frauen von Como und von Bristol City und von Baldano, Baldona, muss ich gleich nochmal nachgucken. Jetzt bestimmt gerade, ach, Bada Lona. Es ist in Spanien irgendwo, wenn ich es hier richtig sehe. Du bist gemutet, Fabian, du darfst mich gerne jetzt bewerben.
Bada Lona ist bei Barcelona, also quasi Barcelona.
Gut, dann war ich da ja sogar schon mal. Na ja gut, sorry. Aber ja, interessant, wie sich das entwickelt. Aber sehr gut, dann haben wir jetzt nämlich mal wieder Como geupdatet und wir überhalten es natürlich im Blick. Bin ich wirklich gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt. Und Multiclub Ownership, das ist, es ist so traurig, aber inzwischen muss man ja einfach bei jedem Verein, über den wir sprechen, der irgendwie so Erfolg hat, muss man sagen, ja, aber einmal ganz kurz, denen gehören noch die fünf Vereine oder die Milliarden kommen übrigens hierher. So ist der moderne Fußball. Wird es bald auch eine Sendung im Rasenfunk geben, wo wir das zumindest am Rande auch nochmal streifen werden, wie sich da eigentlich so die Landschaft verändert hat. Kommt nächste Woche, wenn alles gut geht. Abonniert den Tribüngespräch feed. Ich würde sagen, wir haben jetzt indirekt immer schon mal wieder über Real gesprochen, weil eben die halbe Realjugend jetzt ein bisschen vereinfacht gesagt bei Como ihr auch spielt mit den Rückkaufoptionen. Dann lass doch mal auch mit dem Thema weitermachen, Fabian. Du hast ja auch schon angekündigt. Wir alle haben mitbekommen, in der Königsklasse, in der Champions League läuft es mal wieder gut für Real. In der Liga, tja, so ein bisschen durchwachsen. Aber was will man auch machen? Es wird MVP fehlt, also ist denen überhaupt ein Vorwurf zu machen?
Naja, es ist auf jeden Fall ein großes Umbruchsjahr bei Real Madrid. Du hast gerade schon Reals Jugend angesprochen und der neue Trainer Arbeloa baut tatsächlich viele Spieler von der Real Jugend ein ins erste Team, was sehr, sehr mutig ist, was ich eigentlich fast kein Trainer vor ihm getraut habe, soweit ich das irgendwie nachverfolgen kann. Er kommt ja als Trainer von der zweiten Mannschaft, kennt die Jungs natürlich. Aber trotzdem war es eigentlich meistens so, dass die Trainer nicht wirklich das grüne Licht bekommen haben, von oben auf die Jugend zu setzen. Und Arbeloa hat so einen kleinen Freifahrtschein im Moment und teilweise macht das auch dann richtig gut. Wir sehen jetzt in den letzten Spielen diesen Mittelfeldspieler Thiago Pitarch, der sehr viel spielt. Nicht immer gut, aber konstant. Und da kommen wir gleich auf eine große Baustelle von Real Madrid, die sie eigentlich seit Anfang der Saison haben, mit dem großen Umbruch, mit auch dem Trainerwechsel zu Xavi Alonso. Das Mittelfeld bei Real Madrid ist nach der Ära Großmoderich, Casimiro war ein bisschen länger schon her, aber ist auf jeden Fall nach wie vor eine große Baustelle bei Real Madrid. Und nach wie vor glaube ich so ein bisschen die Achilles-Verse der Weißen, denn da glaube ich ist am meisten zu holen, wenn ich jetzt gleich auf das Viertelfinale der Bayern gegen Real Madrid vielleicht herausblicke. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, wie es im Moment löst mit diesem jungen Pitac, denn zum Beispiel sitzt ein Kammerwinger auf der Bank. Und das ist eigentlich schon ein kleines Statement auch in der Hinsicht. Und er hat jetzt einen großen Vorteil in den letzten Wochen herausgearbeitet, sage ich jetzt mal. Und zwar war es Federico Valverde wieder ins Mittelfeld zu ziehen, der ja lange Rechtsverteidiger spielen musste, aufgrund vieler Verletzungen. Dort ist jetzt wieder Trent Alexander-Arnold, ziemlich viel am Werk nach seinen tausend kleinen Verletzungen, die er hatte am Anfang. Das ist so auch ab und zu wieder Carvajal, der wieder langsam, aber sicher dann herangeführt werden soll nach seiner langen Verletzung. Sprich, Federico Valverde darf wieder ins Mittelfeld. Und dass der ganz gut Fußball spielen kann, hat jetzt City auch im Hinspiel erlebt. Wobei, da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, also diese drei Tore, das war schon ein Ausnahmespiel. Also so ein Spiel wird der Junge nicht mehr machen. Seit der Karriere, glaube ich jetzt einfach mal. Also das war Wahnsinn, was der da diese drei Tore wieder gemacht hat. Und er hat da im Hinspiel eigentlich City im Alleingang mehr oder weniger erledigt. Und es ist interessant, finde ich, wie Real Madrid es jetzt auch umgestellt hat in den letzten Wochen durch diese. Eigentlich spielen sie im Moment ohne MAP in 4-4-2. Sprich, sie haben eigentlich vier Leute im Mittelfeld, machen das ziemlich dicht. Auch Brahim Dias und Vinicius gehen eigentlich ziemlich weit zurück und warten natürlich auf Umschaltsituationen, was wir bei City ganz gut gesehen haben. Wenn der Ball gewonnen wird, dann kommt es den Steilpass auf Vinicius oder eben auf Brahim, wenn die frei sind, und dann ziehen die durch und dann sind sie vorne natürlich absolut brandgefährlich. Haben natürlich dadurch auch hinten eine gewisse Stabilität, denn auch die Abwehr ist nach wie vor, geht so, würde ich sagen. Antonio Rüdiger leistet sich da nach wie vor das ein oder andere Schamützel, vor allen Dingen auch nicht auf dem Platz, sondern schon auf dem Platz, aber nicht während der 90 Minuten, sondern oft auch danach oder davor. Es gab eine ziemlich krasse Szene gegen Getafe, wo sie verloren haben, da ist er einem Spieler schon krass abschließt.
Er geht mit den Knien auf den Brustkorb, oder?
Ja, es sieht sehr absichtlich aus. Also man kann das fast nicht als unabsichtlich bewerten, wie es er selber auch gemacht hat.
Er hat sich doch dafür entschuldigt, Fabian. Er hat doch gesagt, ja, weil der Spieler gesagt hat, er wollte mich umbringen, hat er gesagt, ja, hätte ich ihn umbringen wollen, dann hätte ich es getan. Ja, okay.
Ja, genau.
Danke für diese Einsicht. Wirklich, wirklich kann man wirklich stolz sein, dass so jemand im deutschen Nationalteam offenbar eingeplant ist.
Es ist, es ist schwierig, dass er jetzt ist, er wirklich schon sehr erfahren und ist lange dabei im Geschäft. Und man kann es gar nicht verstehen, dass er sich immer noch zu solchen Sachen dann hinreißen lässt. Auch ich weiß gar nicht, was los war nach dem City-Game, nach dem Rückspiel mit Guardiola hat er sich gefetzt, mit Donnarumma hat er sich gefetzt nach dem Spielen und diskutiert. I don't know, warum der nicht die Ruhe hat, die er eigentlich haben müsste. Er spielt bei Real Madrid, hat eine blendende Karriere hinter sich, könnte eigentlich ruhig abspielen, aber tut er nicht. Und der einzige gesetzte Innenverteidiger, glaube ich, bei Real Madrid ist Dianne Huisen und daneben spielt hat ab und zu, also jetzt gerade wieder mehr Rüdiger. Dann hatten wir Alaba auch mal wieder ab und zu versucht, aber der ist auch noch weit weg von der Form, die er mal hatte, ist er auch verständlich nach diesen ganzen krassen Verletzungen und natürlich auch dem Alter geschuldet inzwischen. Naja, und dann haben wir noch den Asensio, den Jungen, der halt auch einfach zum einen ist er noch jung und zum anderen hat er ja auch noch so ein paar Geschichten aus der Vergangenheit mitzutragen. Und nun ja, es ist auch bei Real Madrid, wie gesagt, in der Verteidigung noch nicht alles grün wieder oder noch alles Gold, was glänzt. Links-Verteidigung hat einen sehr neuzugangen von Carreras von Benfica, Lissabon zurückgeholt auch. Hat nicht gezündet, jetzt spielt im Moment Fran Gasier, das ist eigentlich so die Nummer 2 oder 3 auf der Links-Verteidiger-Position, macht es aber eigentlich ganz gut. Mendy hat sich wieder verletzt. Also Real Madrid strauchelt so ein bisschen durch die Saison, hat vor allem, finde ich, im Mittelfeld eine defensive Probleme, hat in der Liga jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen zweimal verloren. Wie gesagt, einmal gegen Getafe zu Hause, einmal bei Osasuna, hat jetzt ein bisschen abgelassen. Vier Punkte, glaube ich, sind sie jetzt in Tabasa. Aber in der Champions League waren sie wieder on point und hatten tatsächlich wieder mal das richtige Rezept gegen Guardiola City. Und deswegen muss auch Bayern aufpassen. Die Frage wird natürlich jetzt sein, Mbappé kommt jetzt wieder, Jude Bellingham wird wiederkommen. Also bei Bellingham bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie das jetzt ist. Er wird jetzt langsam wieder einsteigen. Mbappé hat jetzt gegen City schon wieder ein bisschen gespielt. Und es ist schon kurios auch zu sehen, Mbappé hat geknipst, als er gespielt hat. Und Vinicius war dann eher im Schatten gestanden. Jetzt ist Mbappé weg gewesen. Vinicius ist jetzt wieder der Man to Go vorne, macht die Tore, ist die wichtigste Anspielstation. Und zusammen haben sie noch nicht wirklich hundertprozentig funktioniert. Jetzt müssen sie aber wieder zusammen funktionieren. Und da bin ich mal gespannt, wie die das dann jetzt in den nächsten Wochen hinbekommen. Denn ich denke dann Brahim Dias, der eigentlich eine tolle Formel im Moment hat, der wird dann mit Sicherheit wieder auf die Reservebank wechseln. Und da bin ich mal gespannt, wie es weitergeht bei Real Madrid. Noch sind sie überall dabei. Königsklasse sowieso aufgepasst. Auch in der Liga, vier Punkte kann man wegmachen. Aber es ist eine schwierige Saison für die Königlichen, die tatsächlich so eine kleine Achterbahnfahrt immer wieder hinnehmen, Woche zu Woche.
Aber was ist denn mit den Problemen, die wir unter Xabi Alonso identifiziert haben? Also Arbeit gegen den Ball? Frage auch, wie folgen die Spieler den Anweisungen des Trainers? Das waren ja so eigentlich so mit die Hauptthemen, die dann zu schlechten Ergebnissen geführt haben und die dann zu seiner Entlassung geführt haben. Ist denn das jetzt besser geworden unter Arbeloas?
Ich denke ja und ich denke, es hat wahrscheinlich auch vor allen Dingen damit zu tun, dass Arbeloas den Spielern mehr zuhört, vor allen Dingen den Rudelführern. Vinicius da gehört auch dazu, aber auch Bellingham, wo er jetzt natürlich verletzt war im Barpé und so weiter. Er hört ein bisschen mehr auf die Spieler, Valverde natürlich als Kapitän und das funktioniert natürlich dann ein bisschen besser. Die laufen ein bisschen mehr für ihren Trainer, hat man das Gefühl, sie kämpfen ein bisschen mehr für ihren Trainer. Sie haben immer noch ihre Aussetzer, wie wir gesagt haben, in der Liga haben sie ja dann doch diese zwei Spiele jetzt vor kurzem verloren gegen Gegner, die sie normalerweise links liegen lassen. Das war ein bisschen überraschend, also es ist nach wie vor, wie gesagt, nicht alles richtig gut bei Real Madrid. Aber er hat es zumindest geschafft, die Mannschaft hinter sich zu bringen. Er verteidigt die Mannschaft auch nach jeder Pressekonferenz, er nimmt sämtliche Schuld, wenn irgendwas ist, auf sich. Und ich glaube, das gefällt der Mannschaft und sie gibt tatsächlich einen Takt mehr, als sie vielleicht für den Trainer Xabi Alonso gegeben hätten.
Ja, weiß man jetzt auch nicht, wie man das bewerten soll, ehrlicherweise. Also ohne jetzt Xabi Alonso zu sehr in Schutz nehmen zu wollen. Aber zeigt ja, wie fragil das ganze Gebilde ist und definitiv. Ja, aber interessant. Und gerade eben, was sich da auch im Mittelfeld verändert hat und so ein 4-4-2 mit Vinicius und Mbappé vorne drin. Wenn die eine Abstimmung miteinander haben, viel Spaß.
Wenn sie die haben, dann wird es interessant. Wie gesagt, aufpassen bei diesen schnellen Umschaltsaktionen, weil die Bayerns sind blitzschnell und torgefährlich. Wo man sie knacken kann, ist im Mittelfeld vor allen Dingen und dann eben auch in der Defensive. Aber wie gesagt, bei Ballverlust aufgepasst.
Wir schauen es uns auf jeden Fall genau an. Solltet ihr jetzt auch hier bei mir im Hintergrund was hören, der Nachbar kriegt Pellets geliefert. Also heute ist es offenbar einfach eine dieser Sendungen. Die gibt es manchmal. Hier läuft es also ein bisschen schlechter als bei Manchester United. Was für eine gekünstete Überleitung. Aber, Uli, wir wollen nochmal, wir haben über Benjamin Cesko in der letzten Sendung schon kurz gesprochen. Aber insgesamt ist die Entwicklung von United ja wirklich beachtenswert. 54 Punkte sind es jetzt. Rang 3 hat man und man hat vor allem schon einen ordentlichen Vorsprung auf den ersten Nicht-Champions League-Platz. Und ich würde jetzt einfach mal aus der Ferndiagnose sagen, ein Name ist dafür verantwortlich, neben Benjamin Cesko. Und das ist Kerik.
Ja, also er hat schon auch andere Namen gebracht, die dann wiederum dafür verantwortlich sind, dass dem so ist, wie es ist. Aber ja, das ist so. Also Michael Kerik ist, ich war da ja äußerst skeptisch, muss ich sagen, weil die bisherige Trainerstation bei Middlesbrough, also ich nehme jetzt mal diesen Interim-Stint, den es ja schon mal gab, nicht unbedingt mit rein, auch wenn der sehr gut war, aber die bisherige Trainerstation bei Middlesbrough, die war sowohl als auch zunächst sehr gut und dann aber auch so ein bisschen ausgeblutet. Und der Typ Michael Kerik, den wir vielleicht alle noch als Spieler in Erinnerung haben, ist ein ganz eigener, also jetzt nicht der Charismatischste von allen, sondern eher ruhig, so Typ Fußballcomputer, hat immer alles relativ entspannt so geregelt, aber ist nie auffällig geworden, ist jetzt auch kein The Rock Charisma-Bombe oder so was, sondern ist halt der, der er ist und das ist bei Manchester United selten, was den Eigenschaften Cocktail betrifft, gut für einen Manager. Sondern da braucht es oft schon jemanden, der– die Engländer sagen ja– so schön larger than life ist, also jemand, der wirklich all das zu handeln weiß, der die Presse entsprechend bespielt, der die Spiele aber auch entsprechend bespielt, der auf vielen verschiedenen Ebenen all die Erfahrungen gemacht hat. Das heißt als Spieler, damit die ihn ernst nehmen, auch die Legenden, das ist ja nicht ganz unwichtig. Und dabei eben auch die Spieler, der Verein und letztlich dann auch der mediale Zirkus, der ja einfach viel, viel größer ist rund um United als um jedes andere Team. Das heißt, ich war da äußerst skeptisch von Woche zu Woche, aber wird es ehrlicherweise immer besser. Und all das, was man von innen raushört, hat sich Karik mit seinem Trainerteam clever aufgestellt. Sie lösen das bis dato sehr gut. Das kommt logischerweise auch bei Ineos an, sodass, glaube ich, seine Chancen steigen, wenngleich noch nicht im Ansatz eine Entscheidung getroffen ist. Das muss auch gar nicht sein, weil sie immer noch zwei Monate Zeit haben, um sich das anzugucken.
Und was hat er spielerisch verändert mit United? Also, was wir mitbekommen, ist ja quasi, dass dann eben Cesco wieder trifft und so weiter, und das wird ja dann auch hier thematisiert. Aber die wenigsten sehen ja dann wirklich viele Spiele von United. Also, was für einen Fußball lässt er denn spielen?
Also, zunächst mal, das ist ja wahrscheinlich das, was es am besten umreißt, und das ist auch tatsächlich so, das werdet ihr ja alle mitbekommen, aber es ist auch die Systemdiskussion gewesen. Also, Ruben Amorim hat ja, das ist ja wie eine Sekte gewesen, hat der an seiner Fünferkette festgehalten. Was natürlich dazu geführt hat, dass du im Vergleich zu Karik, der jetzt, man kann sich so vorstellen wie bei Una Emery ungefähr, ist ein 4-2-2-2 mehr oder weniger. So kann man sich es ungefähr vorstellen bei ihm. Das ist im Aufbau eher ein 4-2-4. Wird dann hoch zum 3-2-5. Im Wesentlichen ist es, deswegen war das Spiel jetzt am Wochenende gegen Esten Villa, das Spiel um Platz drei sozusagen so spannend, weil es im Wesentlichen ein Treffen der Stile war sozusagen. Also lange, lange abwartend und dann zum richtigen Zeitpunkt aber aggressiv. Und dann das schnellstmögliche Spielen in die Spitze. Gerne auch mit langen Bällen und je weniger Ballbesitz wir haben, umso besser ist das. Aber an dieser Systemdiskussion, die ist in dem Fall nicht so hochgehängt. Ich bin da nicht immer so glücklich drüber, wenn viel über Vierer oder Fünferkette gesprochen wird. In dem Fall ist es aber aus dem Grund schon mal super sinnvoll, weil dadurch, dass Amorim immer mit Fünferkette gespielt hat, gab es nur drei Mittelfeldspieler. Und diese drei Mittelfeldspieler hatten, seiner Meinung nach, einen gewissen Profilstandard zu bringen. Und das schloss zum Beispiel Kobi Maynu aus. Weil den mochte er nicht. Er hatte immer lieber so Allround-Läufer-Mittelfeldspieler lieber als diesen Carrick-artigen Kobi Maynu. Und da ist es schon die Lösung des Ganzen. Seitdem der da ist, sieht Kobi Maynu wieder genau aus, wie der der war, bevor Amorim da ist. Ich sage das immer so spaßeshalber, in den USA könnten die Fans Amorim verklagen, weil er ihn nicht hat spielen lassen. Da gäbe es sicherlich irgendeinen juristischen Zugang dazu. Seitdem der weg ist und Maynu wollte ja noch United im Winter ganz gerne verlassen, spielt der wieder genauso, wie er immer spielt. Das hat zur Folge, dass Bruno Fernandes nach vorne rücken konnte und eben nicht Doppel-Sechser war. Das hat einigermaßen funktioniert, weil Bruno Bruno ist neben Casimiro. Aber vielleicht ist er einfach kein Sechser, sondern aktuell ist das der beste Spieler der Liga. Und es ist noch nicht mal knapp. Also der performt rauf und runter gerade. Und alleine diese zwei Personalien sind durch diesen Systemwechsel freigesetzt worden. Weitere logischerweise auch. Also die Innenverteidigung zu dritt war jetzt auch nicht so stark, wie wenn nur zwei spielen, dann kann Schau wieder nach außen rücken. Das hilft im Aufbau schon mal enorm. Und dann Dorgu etwas weiter nach vorne. Ist auch viel besser als auf Wingback. Amad scheint fast losgelöst zu sein. Der hat das auf der rechten Außenverteidigung-Position okay gemacht, aber halt auch nur okay. Und dann spielen plötzlich halt Cesko und Mbömo. Und Cesko wurde auch zum Teil nur eingewechselt, will ich jetzt gar nicht nur so sagen. Aber alles in allem haben die eine... Das ist das, worum es mir eigentlich geht. Wenn du United-Spiele im Moment siehst, weißt du, was du kriegst, es ist eine ganz klare Identität. Jeder weiß, was zu tun ist. Und das machen sie in so einer Entspanntheit einfach. Und das muss man Kerik einfach hoch anrechnen. Das hat nämlich nur Wochen gedauert.
Ja, ich wollte nur ganz kurz wegen Mainu rein. Ich glaube, da kann sich United wirklich bedanken, dass Kerik da zu dem Zeitfenster auch im Janu übernommen hat. Denn ich weiß aus Neapel, dass Neapel sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viel probiert hat. Und anscheinend Richtung Mainu und wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht so weit weg war, was zumindest jetzt eben er wollte. Auch da hat sicherlich McTominay auch eine Rolle gespielt und so. Also das glaube ich hat Napoli gut gemacht. Aber dann kam eben dieser Trainerwechsel und dann war eigentlich auch sofort klar, dass das nichts wird. Also ich glaube, dass ist jetzt wirklich aus Vereinssicht sehr gut gelaufen, weil stelle mal vor, die hätten den wirklich im Winter abgegeben. Das glaube ich, wäre ihnen extrem um die Ohren geflogen, weil da reden wir halt auch noch über einen Spieler, der vom Alter her diesen Verein wahrscheinlich auch sehr, sehr lange prägen kann.
Und vor allen Dingen war es einfach auch immer so in der Geschichte United, und die ist ja jetzt nicht so schlecht, dass die besten Mannschaften immer aufgebaut waren durch Academy-Spieler. Das ist den Menschen auch nicht ganz unwichtig. Also man wird immer so als weltweites zu Recht auch Monstrum betrachtet. Manchester United, das ist auch so. Aber die Kernmannschaften haben immer, immer, immer aus Carrington bestanden. Und Maynoud ist, also da gab es ja nie, das ist ja das Problem. Es gab ja nie Zweifel darüber. Also wenn du in die Fangemeinde mal reingefragt hast, hat jeder gesagt, ja gut, was machen wir hier? Also der Typ ist ja ganz offensichtlich für den aktuellen Fußball wie gemalt. Das ist perfekt. Und gerade für so ein leicht umschaltlastigeres Spiel, das ist jemand, der kann in der ersten, zweiten Spielphase eigentlich alles. Und der checkt es einfach. Er checkt es einfach. Er hat es drauf. Und wenn, also das ist ja so ein Duo, das es da jetzt gibt mit Carrick und ihm. Ich würde mal davon ausgehen, dass Michael Carrick dem mit, mit, mit einer solchen, ja, einfach, das ist natürlich, dass er ihm sagen kann, was zu tun und zu lassen ist. Der wird den hundertprozentig weiterbringen in seinem fußballerischen Leben. Und da ist eh schon so viel da an Intelligenz und so was. Sodass ich einfach denke, das ist einfach nur perfekt für alle Seiten, dass das jetzt endlich so ist. Casemiro profitiert davon auch enorm zum Beispiel. Also Casemiro ist jetzt wieder jemand, der das macht Carrick auch geschickt. Den kann er manchmal so positionieren, dass der nach hinten fällt, um sozusagen das Pressing anzuziehen oder das United sich erst einmal den Pressing entzieht. Beides möglich. Und Maynu ist dann derjenige, der den Ball direkt wieder weiter aufnimmt. Plus auch noch ein oder andere Mal ganz ordentlich mitverteidigt. Auch das hilft enorm. Das habe ich bei uns im Podcast immer so gesagt, das ist das Common-Sense-System, das Carrick gerade laufen lässt. Das ist all das, was wir auch aufgestellt hätten. Wenn ich euch jetzt auf der Konsole sagen würde, macht mal aus diesem Kader die beste Aufstellung, dann werdet ihr genau zu dem gekommen. Aber das muss ja nicht falsch sein, sondern im Gegenteil. Das ist halt so logisch und das ist genau richtig, weil die mit den besten Spielstärken auf den Positionen sind, mit den besten Spielstärken.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt anschaue, das Restprogramm von United in der Liga, da sind nur noch zwei Teams mit dabei, die ich als direkte Konkurrenten um Champions League bezeichnen würde. Bei Chelsea muss ich mich schon ein bisschen verbiegen, um das zu glauben. Und dann Liverpool am 35. Spieltag, aber zu Hause im Old Trafford. Sieht ja wirklich so aus, als könnte das jetzt klappen, endlich mal wieder.
Also ich bin mir eigentlich fast sicher, dass die Platz 3 machen werden inzwischen, weil sie haben auch, und das ist ja auch so ein Punkt, sie haben weiterhin den Kader, der ein bisschen seltsam zusammengestellt ist, auf manchen Positionen äußerst verwahrlost, auf anderen Positionen dafür aber richtig gute Experten. Und das ist in der Premier League nie so schlecht. Also sie haben für das, was sie spielen wollen, die richtigen Leute wie im BIMO und so weiter. Ich muss mir jetzt gerade mal schnell das Programm auch anschauen, weil bei United ist es geht es nämlich nicht immer so sehr um die Stärke des Gegners, sondern vor allen Dingen darum, wie viel Ball der hat. Also anders formuliert, je direkter sie spielen können, je reaktiver sie spielen können, umso höher sind die Siegchancen. Das ist auch der größte Punkt noch unter Michael Carrick. Der hat es bis dato geschafft. Gerade bei Manchester ist mir das in den letzten Jahren super schwierig über die Lippen gekommen. Aber so etwas wie eine Balance, eine Ausgewogenheit im Spiel zu haben. Richtiges, wohltemperiertes Angreifen, aber zeitgleich auch wieder Restverteidigungen und dann in den Phasen, in denen sie nur verteidigen, aber trotzdem so eine Mini-Restoffensive zu haben und so weiter. Das scheint so zu sein, als ist vieles von dem am richtigen Punkt. Aber ich traue dem Ganzen noch nicht so ganz. Also wir sind immer noch in dieser Ole Gunnar Solskjaer-Situation mit einem entscheidenden Unterschied. Solskjaer hat damals auch 19 oder so am Stück nicht verloren, die meisten davon gewonnen und dann haben sie ihm den Job gegeben. Nur damals bin ich von Spiel zu Spiel da gesessen und habe gesagt, ja, aber es hat sich dort nichts verändert. Also es ist ja nichts besser geworden. Es ist derselbe Stiefel. Sie lächeln nur alle beim selben Stiefel. Und das ist jetzt unter Carey anders. Aber der letzte Schritt, den ich noch sehen will, ist, was macht er gegen die tiefen Gegner. Da waren jetzt auch einige gute Beispiele dabei. Das will ich jetzt gar nicht sagen. Also Everton, ja, wobei Everton war nicht gut, aber es war zumindest gewonnen. Crystal Palace war, ja, das war okay, vermutlich. Fulham war auch okay. Da habe ich zum ersten Mal diese Frage gestellt, aber es war auch okay. Bournemouth, das werden sie im Kreuz haben. Leeds könnte ich mir auch noch vorstellen. Brentford wird dann hässlich. Sunderland, da möchte ich es noch mal sehen. Das sind so die zwei Spiele, wo ich abwarte, wenn sie das auch ordentlich bespielen, dann traue ich dem Ganzen und dann würde ich auch behaupten, kriegt Kerik den Job final. Also er ist ja nicht Caretaker, sie nennen ihn ja ganz offiziell Head Coach, aber dann behaupte ich, kriegt er den Job.
Du, wer weiß, direkt vor dem Sunderland-Spiel spielen sie zu Hause gegen Liverpool. Vielleicht haben sie es da schon klar gemacht. Und dann ist es auch, dann ist es vielleicht auch einfacher, einen tiefen Gegner zu bespielen. Also wirklich interessante Entwicklungen und bedeutet ja auch, dass sich wieder ein bisschen was verschiebt in der Premier League, zumindest verschieben könnte. Also die Top 6, die Big 6, jetzt ist der 6. auch wirklich wieder ein bisschen bigger.
Dafür ist dann nächstes Jahr ein Zweitligist aus den Big 6. Wenn es blöd läuft.
Du redest von Tottenham.
Von Tottenham, ja. Mehr als möglich.
Okay, gut, vielleicht reden wir da gleich nochmal drüber.
Das wäre Wahnsinn. Da muss ich einfach nur mal vorstellen. Diese wirtschaftliche Big 6, die ja unangreifbar ist für die nächsten Jahrzehnte, wenn das alles einfach nur so bliebe, wenn die runtergehen würden, das wäre unfassbar, was das verändern würde in der Premier League.
Ja, wobei es ja auch im wirtschaftlichen Sinne Gründe hat bei Tottenham. Die waren halt einfach durch den Stadionbau und so weiter die Hände auch ein bisschen gebunden.
Ja gut, aber ein Jahr, nee, würde ich gar nicht so sagen wollen. Die waren zwischenzeitlich trotzdem laut dieser Deloitte, Deloui, weiß ich nicht, wie man das ausspricht, Liste, trotzdem das reichste Team der Liga. Also die hatten zwischenzeitlich trotzdem den höchsten Einnahmenüberschuss, zumindest auch nach PSA, gerechnet. Die könnten, wenn sie wollten. Also so ist es nicht. Und die haben auch ganz schön. Die haben halt einfach nur Absagen kassiert ohne Ende. Aber die, die könnten schon ausgeben. So ist es nicht. Also die hätten jetzt auch im Winter nochmal ordentlich nachlegen können. Weil ich auch immer nachgefragt habe im Verein, wie ist es denn? Also, musstet ihr eventuell sparen oder nicht? Und dann haben die gesagt, nee, nee, nee. Wir haben einfach nur keine Verstärkung auf dem Markt gesehen. Und wir wollten halt nicht den nächsten etwas tiefenhaften Spieler verpflichten, sondern wenn, dann hätten wir uns sicher sein müssen. Aber die haben ja einfach mal Conor Gallagher aus Atletico abgelöst, obwohl sie den überhaupt nicht gebraucht haben. Also das ist ja, das macht es ja so irre, weil sie haben 5-6 Baustellen und die einzige Baustelle, auf der nichts los ist, da knallen sie das Geld halt hin und holen Conor Gallagher. Das ist an sich ein nachvollziehbarer Deal, aber halt überhaupt nicht, was sie gebraucht haben. Und ich habe die Frage deshalb gestellt, ich will jetzt nicht zu weit gehen, ich mache auch gleich fertig, aber ich habe die Frage deshalb gestellt, weil im letzten Winter war es schon genauso, Verletzungen ohne Ende und die haben einfach nichts gemacht. Und dann habe ich auch da schon gesagt, sag mal, habt ihr Schwierigkeiten finanziell? Nee, wir haben hier Festgeldkonten. Okay, gut, keine weiteren Fragen.
Ja, aber okay, dann bleiben wir jetzt einfach bei Tottenheim. Also du hast natürlich recht, sie geben irre viel Geld aus. Man hat allein in den letzten fünf Jahren, also fünf Saisons, hat man ein Transferminus von 760 Millionen Euro, laut transfermarkt.de, aufgehäuft. Also so viel Geld kann wirklich nicht im Stadion gebunden sein. Da war ich noch auf einem alten Stand, sage ich mal. Ja, warum stehen sie denn dann auf Platz 16 mit nur einem Punkt vor der Abstiegszone?
Unter anderem deshalb, weil die großen Deals nicht gezündet haben in den letzten Jahren. Und deshalb haben sie sich ja auch im Recruitment zum Beispiel völlig neu aufgestellt. Und trotzdem haben sie nicht gezündet. Ich kann viele der Deals verstehen sogar. Und viele sind, also man muss vielleicht so rum rangehen. Die wollten Morgengibbs White haben im Sommer und waren nah dran. Also das hat dann letztlich zur Folge gehabt, dass bei Morgengibbs White bei der Geburt des zweiten Kindes, was ganz furchtbares passiert ist, es hat ihn persönlich sehr gebunden. Und deshalb hat, also so munkelt man in England, deshalb hat er auch keine größere Entscheidung Richtung Umzug treffen wollen, was ich total nachvollziehen kann. Und dann gab es eine der bizarsten Szenarien, die ich je gesehen habe, dass dann plötzlich Marinakis ihn wie so ein kleines Kind an der Hand hält und dann die Vertragsverlängerung bei Nottingham bekannt gibt. Mit Morgen gibt es weit, behaupte ich schon, wäre einiges anders gelaufen. Fast ähnlich lief es bei Average ESA. Da war auch schon so gut wie alles auf Vollzug. Also wir waren auch schon vorbereitet, dass wir das alles besprechen. Und dann kommt halt kurz vor Schluss ausgerechnet Arsenal und schnappt ihnen den weg. Und dann haben sie halt zum Beispiel noch Xavi geholt. Und das ist per se gar kein schlechter Deal gewesen, finde ich. Also so als Spieler, nur das musst du halt immer menschlich dynamisch betrachten. Und da hat er halt einfach Schwierigkeiten und kommt rein in einen Kader, der ebenfalls schon ein paar Schwierigkeiten hat. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist einfach, das kaufe ich total. Es sind unfassbare Verletzungs-Sorgen. Also ich habe überhaupt keine medizinische Ahnung. Deswegen kann ich noch nicht mal die richtigen Fragen dazu stellen. Aber das ist jetzt das zweite Mal in Folge, dass die wirklich gerade so elf Leute zusammenkratzen können. Da kann aus meiner Sicht was nicht stimmen. Zunächst sah es bei Thomas Frank okay aus. Das war ganz klar kommuniziert. Sie werden keinen spielerischen Ansatz fahren, sondern sie wollen Zentrum zumachen, umschalten und Standards vor allen Dingen erzielen. Das hat auch bis Oktober, November eigentlich ganz okay geklappt. Mal besser, mal schlechter. Das war okay. Man sieht auch, dass zum Beispiel, finde ich zumindest, dass er gewirkt hat, weil sie in der Champions League weiter sind. Das ist immer so meine Idee gewesen zu sagen. Erstens setzt sich die Physis, die Frank wollte, besser durch in der Champions League, weil sie im Vergleich zu den anderen in Europa einfach einen Unterschied macht. Und zweitens ist das einfach ein umschaltzentrierterer Wettbewerb, als das in der Premier League im Moment der Fall ist. Das heißt, ich habe nicht gesehen, dass es funktioniert hat und trotzdem gab es so atmosphärische Störungen oft bei Frank. Also wenn ihr euch an das Van de Veen Tor erinnert, gegen Kopenhagen, kurz davor hat er eben den Handschlag verweigert und noch jemand und da gab es schon so die und Van de Veen ist im Übrigen wird gerade gerüchteweise gestreut soll rumgelaufen sein in Enfield da am Trainingskomplex und soll einfach schon mal gesagt haben, so die Klassiker ist alles nicht mein Thema. Mein Berater spricht gerade mit Barcelona, eure Schuld nicht meine. Und von diesen Fällen soll es da ein paar geben. Romero, der als Kapitän kurz bevor er seinen ich muss noch mal nachdenken, ich glaube siebten Platzverweis gemacht hat in 150 Spielen oder so. Hat der einmal Social Media rund umgeschlagen und hat das Board beschimpft und noch mal ins Poste Koglu gelobt, der war ja so toll. Also auch völlig, das ist der Kapitän, völlig wirre Zustände da. Und dann geht er halt ins Spiel und tritt einen wieder mal völlig aus dem Leben. Und was willst du da sagen? Und Solenki fehlt dir dann einfach an allen Ecken und Enden, wenn er nicht spielt und und und. Und jetzt haben sie halt so reagiert mit Igor Tüdor, dass sie Frank entlassen haben, haben sich für einen Caretaker, das haben wir beim letzten Mal, glaube ich, besprochen, als ich so etwas zu füsant gesagt habe, wollen sie nicht mehr. Und dann hat Christian auch zurecht gesagt, nee, war gar nicht so schlecht und ich habe es ja sachlich dann auch so eingeordnet. Aber ich sage es euch, wie es ist, das ist mit der Bosnian-Loders-Assistent, den ich je gesehen habe in der Premier League. Das ist irre. Der macht wirklich, mir hat das Teil von Korkut, hat mir das mal erklärt, wie er als Feuerwehrmann an Dinge rangeht. Superspannend, dass er sagt, ich verändere einfach alles. Egal, was der Alte gemacht hat, ich mach es genau andersrum. Ist nicht meine Philosophie, wurscht. Ich versuche nur, überall, an jeder Stelle neue Reize zu setzen. Neues Personal, neue Position, damit alle noch einmal vollgeschärft sind und reingehen. Er hat auch gesagt, das kannst du 6 Wochen durchziehen, danach will dich niemand mehr sehen. Deswegen hat er aus seiner Sicht auch nirgendwo länger arbeiten können. Außer bei VfB Stuttgart. Außer bei VfB Stuttgart, wo er nämlich...
Da haben wir die Korkut-Falle getappt.
Ja, und das hat er mir dann auch erzählt. Ich hab fast einmal 3 Stunden telefonieren dürfen und hat mir das alles erklärt. War hochinteressant, wie er das dann sozusagen abgeändert hat beim VfB Stuttgart, weil er da auch die Zeit dafür bekommen hat. Anyway, ist kein Teil von Korkut-Podcast. Jedenfalls macht Igor Tudor– das ist ein Teil von Korkut– auf Giancarli im Porsche, was der gerade tut. Der macht das alles in einer Rekordgeschwindigkeit. Das ist völlig, völlig gestört. Nimmt Conor Gallagher zunächst mal ins rechte Mittelfeld und dann aus dem Kader. Und solche Dinge macht er ständig. Jetzt hat er am Wochenende zuerst einmal mit einer Viererkette gespielt, obwohl er vorher unbedingt auf Fünferkette gepaart hat. Das ist einfach nur für mich schon ein Overload. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Spieler auch irgendwann sagen, ey, hat sie nicht alle.
Ja, die Geschichte mit dem Torwart im Champions League-Hinspiel bei Athletik und Dritten auch irre einfach, oder?
Ja, genau. Gut, dass du es sagst. Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich der wichtigste aller Punkte. Also auch das muss man wiederum dazu sagen. Kinski ist sehr ungeduldig als Typ. Der wollte händeringend weg im Winter. Und Tottenham geht ganz fest davon aus, dass der ihre neue Nummer eins ist, weil Vicarrio eigentlich ein richtig guter Torhüter ist, nur das große Problem hat, dass du dem manchmal beim Denken zusehen kannst während eines Spiels. Der hat Riesenprobleme weiterhin bei Ecken. Und jedes Mal, wenn er rauskommt, wird der– der ist ein bisschen leicht auf der Brust– wird er jedes Mal angelaufen und dann passiert ein Fehler. Und wenn ihm dieser Fehler passiert, dann merkst du, dass seine Vorderleute ihm nicht mehr trauen. Und das wiederum setzt ihm enorm zu und dann ist er manchmal einfach wochenlang in einem absoluten Sumpf. Okay, das wissend muss ich bei diesen Maßnahmen, die Tudor da versucht, halt ihn schon mal aussparen, den Vicarrio. Oder du gehst halt voll mit Kinski. Tottenham geht ganz sicher davon aus, dass das ihr Torhüter, wenn nicht in der nächsten Saison, dann in der übernächsten Saison ist, weil sie eh Vicarrio verkaufen wollen. Und jetzt hat er Kinski gekillt, weil also kein Torhüter, mit dem ich seither gesprochen habe, hat mir irgendwas anderes gesagt. Sorry, aber das wird seine Karriere beeinträchtigen. Kannst mir erzählen, was du willst. Und Vicarrio gleichermaßen. Und das in einer Viertelstunde. Also das ist schon... Wow.
Und der hat ja danach nicht mal irgendwie... Also ganz kurz für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die gerade auf dem Schlauch stehen. Hinspiegigen, Atletico, Kinski steht völlig überraschend im Tor, kassiert innerhalb kürzester Zeit drei Gegentore, bei denen er... Bei allen sieht er nicht gut aus, wird dann in der 17. Minute ausgewechselt, fühlt ihn komplikativ und macht jetzt auch nicht unbedingt das Spiel seines Lebens. Aber danach stellt sich ja nicht mal Igo Tudor hin und sagt, es tut mir leid, ich habe da einfach eine Fehlentscheidung getroffen, sondern ja, also das war einfach seltsam.
Ja, er muss vor allen Dingen mit einer Art Borniertheit auch intern sprechen. Die Vereinsführung versucht logischerweise, das noch einigermaßen gutzureden und sagt, sie haben ihn auch gebeten, hart anzupacken und solange sie das Gefühl haben, er packt sie richtig an, darf er weiterarbeiten. Nur das Problem ist, all das, was die Spieler zwischen den Zeilen sagen oder was so durchrutscht, ist halt, sie respektieren ihn nicht. Und ich sage das immer wieder an der Stelle, all das, was wir über Trainer sagen, gilt bei Karik genauso wie bei jedem anderen, also positiv wie negativ. All das, was wir sehen, ist einfach nur, ich bewerte ein fertiges Produkt und versuche halt, rauszufinden, wie war es vorher, wie war es nachher, also schiebe ich dem Trainer eine gewisse Rolle zu. Kann auch sein, dass es nicht Karik war, sondern Steve Hollands, ein Assistent, der bei Southgate auch gedient hat. Kann auch sein, dass es in dem Fall nicht Igor Tudors schuld ist. Nur, was offensichtlich ist, ist, seitdem der da ist, haben sich die Dinge noch mal rapide verschlechtert. Also das hätten sie mit Thomas Frank, glaube ich, so nicht erlebt. Vielleicht ist es einfach auch schon, aber eine Dynamik, die nicht mehr aufzuhalten ist oder war. Fakt ist nur, das ist das Problem für Tottenham, all die anderen Teams, die da unten noch rumschwirren. Also bei Bernhard und den Wolves gehe ich mal davon aus, die sind weg. Und dann gibt es noch Leeds, die mir eigentlich, haben wir glaube ich beim vorletzten Mal besprochen, oder vielleicht ist das schon länger her, die mir eigentlich immer ganz gut gefallen haben. Die haben jetzt auch so ein Ergebnisproblem gerade zwischendrin gehabt, aber die finde ich eigentlich immer noch ganz gut, leistungstechnisch vor allen Dingen. West Ham spielt gerade richtig gut. Also wenn die so spielen würden und man würde jetzt so ab Mitte Januar ansetzen, wären die eher nach oben und nicht nach unten. Also dann würden die Richtung Europa League sogar schauen können, so wie die spielen. Nottingham ist hit and miss. Seit Vito Pereira aber da ist tatsächlich leistungstechnisch deutlich stabiler, vor allen Dingen, weil die Einzelspieler langsam wieder anfangen, Form zu fangen und die Einzigen, die halt Woche für Woche denselben Stoß spielen, sind halt die Spurs und das macht mir so Sorge um die. Also deswegen ist das wirklich real, das ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass die runtergehen, weil ich glaube, die haben es immer noch nicht gecheckt.
Kommen Arsenal-Fans noch durch die Tür? Also das heißt, wir könnten auf eine Saison zu laufen, in der Arsenal Meister wird und die Spurs runtergehen.
Stimmt, das habe ich noch gar nicht bedacht. Das wäre Wahnsinn, das wäre Wahnsinn, das wäre Wahnsinn. Und Tottenham war zwischenzeitlich so viel näher dran an allem, mit Pochettino, wenn du dich erinnerst. Die waren so mit Kane, Sonnen, Moura, wie sie alle hießen, die waren so viel näher dran an der Meisterschaft als Arsenal. Und ja, Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn. Also, man mag sich das gar nicht vorstellen. Und die haben richtig fähige Leute da bei Tottenham. Das sind keine Idioten, sondern das sind Joachim Lange mit seinem Team. Das ist richtig, richtig gut, was die da tun. Die haben auch lange sehr bedacht gearbeitet. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Das ist natürlich eine Saison, in der Daniel Levy zu Beginn den Verein verlassen hat, der ja über Jahre unter anderem dieses Stadion hingezimmert hat. Und natürlich könnt ihr euch vorstellen, in der Art Leute hinterlassen hat in dem Verein. Das ist auch politisch nicht ganz leicht, alles zu lösen, weil das ist schon so, ich sag jetzt mal Hoffenheim, nur auf Netflix-Niveau, was da passiert. Das ist schon so, dass da ganz, ganz viele Kämpfe intern passieren. Nur trotz und alledem müsste dieser Kader idealerweise sogar Champions-League-Qualifikation anpeilen können. Jetzt wissen wir, wir sind weit weg von ideal. Aber zumindest Platz 13, 12, das wäre schon bodenlos. Aber dadurch, das ist ja auch so ein Stammtischsatz. Ja, wenn die nicht Abstiegskampf kennen oder können, oder wenn sie den nicht annehmen, dann werden sie absteigen. Aber Too Good, Too Go Down, glaube ich, zählt nicht in dem Fall. Sondern die haben das große Problem. Also ich habe das, glaube ich, beim letzten Mal auch schon gesagt, es wird dieses Jahr in der Premier League das stärkste Thema der Geschichte runtergehen. Vielleicht auch sogar punktetechnisch. Aktuell sind die Hochrechnungen so, dass es 37 Punkte bräuchte, um drin zu bleiben. Und 10 mehr als in den letzten beiden Jahren. Das alleine zeigt schon mal, wie stark die Liga geworden ist. Und egal, wen es erwischt, Leeds, West Ham, Nottingham, mein Lieber. Die haben Kader, das ist aber, die werden in der Bundesliga straight away Dritter.
Mein Lieber, ja, ich sehe schon. Also da haben wir jetzt ein, da haben wir was in dir ausgelöst. Ich bin froh, dass ich diese Abzweigung mit Nottingham gleich genommen habe. Hat mir zwei große Themen ausgelöst.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Nee, ist ja wirklich hochinteressant und ja. Also da werden wir auf jeden Fall nochmal drüber sprechen, wie es dann, wie es da weiterging bei den Spurs. Aber wenn wir beim Abstiegskampf sind, dann können wir ja auch mal wieder nach Italien blicken und über Krimineze sprechen. Christian, die hattest du uns ganz am Anfang der Saison mal mitgebracht. Da lag der Aufsteiger zwischendurch auf Rang 3. Klar, das war nach drei Spieltagen. Also wir haben es auch damals ja schon entsprechend eingeordnet. Aber du hast uns damals ein bisschen erklärt, wie es zu dieser Überraschung kommen konnte. Jetzt ist es noch nicht so, dass man jetzt hier von einem sicheren Abstieg sprechen müsste. Aber es ist aktuell eben Rang 18 mit 3 Punkten Rückstand aktuell auf Letsche. Ist das so das normale? Es hat sich alles wieder so ein bisschen eingependelt auf dem normalen Niveau, in Anführungszeichen bei Cremonese. Die Anfangseuphorie ist verflogen. Oder woran liegt das, dass es eben jetzt diesen ja dann doch Absturz in der Tabelle gab?
Ja, Max, dann probieren wir jetzt mal die Kurve zu kriegen von Tottenham zu Cremonese. Schauen, ob uns das gelingt. Ein Satz noch zu Vicario, nur zu Tottenham. Also da deutet sehr vieles darauf hin, dass der im Sommer nach Italien zurückkehrt. Inter ist da wohl sehr weit in Gesprächen. Juve ist auch interessiert, die brauchen auch eine 1. Also vielleicht tut es ihm auch dann ganz gut, wieder dahin zurückzukommen, wo er ja auch seinen sportlichen Aufstieg, sage ich mal, gestartet hat. Genau. Ja, Cremonese. Nein, es ist schon, Max, ein bisschen mehr als nur dieses Klassische. Das hat sich jetzt vielleicht einsortiert, denn Anfang Dezember war Cremonese noch auf Rang 9. Ich habe mir extra noch mal die Tabelle angeschaut. Sie hatten nur drei Punkte weniger als Juve, nur um das mal ein bisschen einzuordnen, und hatten zehn Punkte Vorsprung auf den ersten Abstiegsrang. Also die hatten wirklich auch nicht nur dieser Traumstart, sondern es hat schon länger angedauert, dass die einfach über ihre Verhältnisse gespielt haben. Und jetzt aber haben wir das Problem, seit Anfang Dezember haben die 15 Spiele in Folge nicht mehr gewonnen. Also wirklich eine unfassbar lange Serie. Und jetzt sind sie nicht nur da hinten reingerutscht, sondern es schaut im Moment wirklich so aus, als ob sie die schlechtesten Karten hätten. Sie haben jetzt zuletzt gegen die Fiorentina und gegen Lecce, also direkte Konkurrenten, verloren. Sie sind jetzt eben auf dem Abstiegsplatz, haben drei Punkte Rückstand. Und es ist schon komplett jetzt den Bach runtergegangen, muss man sagen. Es kam jetzt auch zum Trainerwechsel unter der Woche. David Nicola, also der Mann, der sie in die Saison geführt hat, ist jetzt entlassen worden. Marc Giampaolo hat übernommen, der auch schon viele Erfahrungen in der Serie hat, gerade mit kleineren Vereinen. War auch schon mal bei Lecce vor, glaube ich, neun oder zehn Jahren in der Serie C, also kennt den Verein. Das interessante an dem Trainerwechsel ist, eigentlich ist David Nicola, hat sich in den letzten Jahren als Feuerwehrmann, als Spezialist entpuppt, der oft eben Mannschaften im Abstiegskampf während der Saison übernommen hat und dann drin gehalten hat und dieses Jahr hat er von Anfang an die Chance bekommen, hat das eben, wie gesagt, monatelang richtig gut gemacht, aber jetzt ist einfach seit Anfang Dezember, kommen die nicht mehr aus dem Loch raus. Ein Sinn bildlich vielleicht, der Name, glaube ich, den die meisten internationalen Zuhörer oder Zuhörerinnen mit Cremonaise verbinden können, ist eben Jamie Vardy, der ja im Sommer nach Cremona gewechselt ist, logisch eine große Nummer. Der hat jetzt auch seit Anfang Dezember nur noch einmal getroffen. Und die Tore von ihm, die er davor auch immer wieder mal geliefert hat, waren halt auch ein Mitgrund, dass sie eben so gut unterwegs waren. Ja, und jetzt bist du halt wirklich so ein Negativstrudel drin. Hast jetzt eben den Trainer gewechselt und musst jetzt wirklich schauen, dass du da irgendwie noch mal die Kurve kriegst. Wie gesagt, sehr schwierig. Also sie haben die direkten Duellen jetzt gegen die Fiorentina. Haben sie zweimal verloren. Gegen Lecce haben sie jetzt verloren. Lecce wirkt sehr gefestigt im Moment. Das ist ähnlich wie die Konstellation wie bei Uli in der Premier League. Also mit Pisa und Hellas sind eigentlich zwei Teams so gut wie weg. Die haben jetzt zwar zuletzt jeweils gewonnen, aber der Rückstand ist eigentlich zu groß. Eigentlich geht es noch um diesen letzten Abstiegsplatz. Und da ist eben die Fiorentina, hat jetzt hin und wieder diese direkten Duellen gewonnen und haben ja schon gesprochen über die Fiorentina. Die hat halt einfach eine andere Qualität, logisch, zur Verfügung. Let's Shame, wie gesagt, hat sich da richtig reingegroovt. Die sind voll in diesem Modus drin. Und im Moment deutet wirklich sehr, sehr viel darauf hin, dass das Gremonese erwischt, obwohl sie diesen überragenden Run von August bis Dezember hatten.
Ja, wie es dann manchmal so geht. Aber ist dann der Kader letztlich dann nicht stabil genug zusammengestellt? Also, was man gesehen hat, aber das ist jetzt leider auch nicht so sehr ja und typisch. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob das was Besonderes ist. Aber irre viele Transferbewegungen in diesem Sommer.
Ja, aber eigentlich war das auch eine Stärke, hat man auch schon angedeutet. Die haben relativ viele erfahrene Spieler geholt, also Abstiegskampfs erfahrene Spieler. Der eine Name, der dafür steht, Federico Basquerotto, den haben sie von Lecce geholt. Der war bei Lecce mit der wichtigste Innenverteidiger. Dann holen sie ihn sozusagen als Aufsteiger. Schwächen damit auch einen direkten Konkurrenten. Also das war schon so ein Signal, oh, okay, Cremonese hat irgendwie erkannt, dass du da auch Leute brauchst, die das kennen. Cremonese war ja sehr lange nicht mehr in der Serie A. Dementsprechend haben sie das eigentlich ganz gut gemacht, haben jetzt im Winter zum Beispiel auch nachgelegt. Sebastiano Luperto, das ist ein sehr erfahrender Innenverteidiger, der kam von Caliere, der spielt halt auch seit Jahren gegen den Abstieg und eigentlich sehr verlässlich. Also eigentlich hat auch da einiges darauf hingedeutet, dass sie das schon gut machen. Also dass das sozusagen das Potenzial schon da ist. Auch da eben im Gegensatz zu anderen kleineren Vereinen im unteren Tabellendrittel, die im Winter gar nicht so viel machen konnten. Also so ein Luperto-Transfer ist schon was, wo du sagst, okay, Aufsteiger holt da nochmal Erfahrungen mit rein. Aber wie gesagt, du bist halt oft, das kennen wir ja glaube ich auch, aus vielen Saisons, aus vielen Ligen. Wenn du mal im Zone negativ strudel drin bist, dann ist das halt auch wahnsinnig schwierig rauszukommen. Sie tun sich offensiv einfach schwer. Also da kommt halt relativ wenig. Wie gesagt, wenn Vardy nicht knipst, Bonazzoli, der hat teilweise am Anfang da Sensationstore geschossen, auch gegen Milan in San Siro zum Sieg. Aber der steht halt auch bei 6 Tore. Also du hast Bonazzoli 6 Tore, Vardy 5 Tore. Und wenn die nicht treffen, dann kommt auch relativ wenig sonst Offensive aus dem Mittelfeld nach. Und dann hast du diesen Negativ-Run. Dann hast du die Fragezeichen im Kopf. Und ja, das ist jetzt im Moment die Gemengelage, die Cremonese wirklich in eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr prekäre Lage jetzt bringt. Ganz klar. Also ich, ich hatte sogar im Gefühl schon vor ein paar Wochen, wenn es blöd für die läuft, dann rutschen die rein. Das Rein-Rutschen ist jetzt mehr als passiert. Und im Moment schaut es sogar danach aus, als ob sie wirklich die schlechtesten Karten auch haben. Also was vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen Hoffnung macht, sie haben noch ein paar direkte Duelles. Sie haben jetzt Parma am Wochenende. Das ist logisch ein wahnsinnig wichtiges Spiel. Sie haben Kaliarin noch. Sie haben Pisa noch. Also sie haben schon noch ein paar Spiele, wo sie dann auch sozusagen gegen diese Direkten was machen können. Aber du musst halt irgendwann wieder ein Spiel gewinnen. Nochmal 15 Spiele in Folge ohne Sieg. Ja, da wird es halt irgendwann schwer. Trotz schönem Polster.
Ich meine, immerhin haben sie einen Trainer, Gianpaolo, der es eben auch kennt von Lettche noch und so weiter. Du hast es ja schon angesprochen. Und einmal nur mal ganz kurz, um das zu verdeutlichen für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Transferbewegungen. Nur wie viele Spieler sind gekommen und gegangen auf dem Papier. Bei Gremonese 100. 148 sind auf dem Papier gekommen und 52 sind auf dem Papier gegangen. Das sind halt wahnsinnig viele Lien. Deswegen darf man da nicht davon ausgehen, dass die jetzt auch alle da im Locker-Room einen Schrank hatten und so weiter. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die in der Halle sich alle umziehen. Aber das macht es halt eben auch so schwierig, ganz viele Dinge zu bewerten. Weil von außen kannst du überhaupt nicht mehr sagen, ist das jetzt eins von diesen typischen, für die, für die italienische Liga, einfach typischen Laigeschäfte oder ist das jetzt wirklich ein Spieler, der nochmal wichtig wird? Aber deswegen wollte ich das nur nochmal kurz ansprechen. Dann lass mal noch gleich, wir haben ja gerade bei Uli auch einen längeren Stint gemacht. Dann machen wir das einfach in Italien jetzt auch. Wollen wir nochmal an die Tabellen spitze blicken, vielleicht auf Rang 3? Du hast mir mitgegeben, dass sich bei Napoli wieder ein bisschen was getan hat.
Ja, müssen wir vielleicht ansprechen. Das passt auch vielleicht so ein bisschen als übergeordnetes Thema. Also wir hatten Napoli in der Saison, konnte auch stark hinter Kritik, weil Napoli, also A, diese katastrophale Champions League-Saison, da müssen wir ja gar nicht drumherum reden, also als italienischer Meister, sich nicht für die Top 24 zu qualifizieren in der Gruppenphase. Das ist logisch eine absolute Katastrophe. Und in der Liga waren sie eigentlich seit Wochen ja schon raus aus den Meisterrennen. Aber, und deswegen wollte ich es halt ansprechen, das, was für Tottenheim gilt mit den Verletzungs-Sorgen, gilt halt für Napoli auch in dieser Saison. Und ja, da können wir uns ganz kurz überreden. Da muss man dann sicherlich auch über Trainingsplanung, übers Trainerteam auch reden. Da wurden wahrscheinlich gewisse Sachen nicht richtig angegangen. Aber Fakt ist, dass Napoli jetzt monatelang 5 ohne Kevin de Bruyne gespielt hat. Sie haben 4 Monate ohne Franck Anguissage gespielt. Romelu Lukaku hat seine ersten Einsatzminuten Ende Januar gehabt. Also der hat von August bis Januar 0 Minuten für seinen Club spielen können. David Neresch, der Napoli im November, Dezember offensiv getragen hat, ist jetzt mittlerweile seit zweieinhalb Monaten raus. Was ich damit sagen will, sie hatten schon nicht nur viele Verletzungsprobleme, sondern auch wirklich die Crème de la Crème. Ah, Scott Mcdominay sollte ich vielleicht noch nennen. Der war jetzt, glaube ich, eineinhalb oder zwei Monate raus. Was ich damit sagen will, ist, wenn man, man kann viel über Trainer sprechen, man kann viel über Ansätze von Clubs sprechen, über Taktik, was man richtig falsch machen kann. Aber es ist halt ein Unterschied, ob ich Fußball spielen kann mit Scott Mcdominay, Kevin de Bruyne, David Neresch und Frank Anguizá. Oder ob ich das halt monatelang ohne die machen muss. Und deswegen, um hier die Klammer zu schließen, Napoli, jetzt kommen die wieder zurück. Am vergangenen Wochenende lagen sie gegen Lecce zur Halbzeit, 1-0 zurück. In der Halbzeit kommen Kevin de Bruyne und Scott Mcdominay. Mcdominay hat sogar sein Comeback-Hem jetzt nach wochenlanger Pause gefeiert. De Bruyne hatte davor schon mal ein, zwei Kurzeinsätze. Ja, und dann wird es ein komplett anderes Spiel in der zweiten Hälfte. Die zwei haben das an sich gezogen. Napoli hat es noch gewonnen, hat jetzt drei in Folge gewonnen, ist nur noch ein Punkt hinter Milan sozusagen. Und deswegen wollte ich das Thema kurz bringen, dass es logisch schon einen großen Unterschied ausmacht, mit welcher Qualität ich halt meine Ideen sozusagen auf dem Feld umsetzen kann. Und ich sage mal so, das hilft uns jetzt nicht mehr weiter in Sachen Meisterkampf in Italien. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, wenn Napoli drei oder vier Punkte mehr hätte, dann würden die Inter noch ein paar zumindest mentale Probleme bereiten. Weil Inter ist jetzt wirklich so ein bisschen übers Spielmodus, hat ein paar Fragezeichen. Napoli ist jetzt einfach zu weit weg. Neun Punkte, das wird nichts mehr. Neun Spieltage vor Schluss. Aber ich habe das Leistegefühl, wenn Napoli auf sechs dran wäre. Napoli traue ich jetzt wirklich zu, dass die auch die nächsten drei, vier, fünf Spiele noch gewinnen. Weil wirklich alle Großen zurückkommen. Weil alle Großen, dürfen wir nicht vergessen, haben ja ein großes Ziel im Sommer. Nämlich die wollen bei der WM auch eine Rolle spielen. Also auch die intrinsische Motivation, glaube ich, vieler Spieler wie von McTominay, wie von de Bruyne und so. Da geht es ja auch darum, was im Juni dann für die passiert. Dementsprechend haben da viele wirklich ein großes Interesse, jetzt auch in diesen letzten Saisonmonaten nochmal richtig in Schwung zu kommen. Und deswegen, schade aus Napolis Sicht, ich glaube echt, mit ein paar Punkten näher, hätten sie vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen, zumindest Druck auf Inter machen können. So logischerweise waren die letzten Monate einfach. Waren sie zu früh oder letzten Wochen, sie waren zu früh, zu weit weg. Und das Thema ist jetzt durch. Aber sie werden total easy und locker in die Champions League kommen.
Ja, und das muss aus Sicht von Lecce auch wirklich schwierig sein. Du führst ab der dritten Minute 1 zu 0. Wir haben ja gerade Lecce indirekt auch mit besprochen. Was hätte das bedeutet? Dann wäre die Situation für Kriminese noch schlechter. Ja, und dann wechseln die halt einfach in der Pause McTominay und de Bruyne ein und machen ja auch direkt dann den Ausgleich.
Und das war wirklich so ein Spiel, nicht nur, weil sie es drehen und sie gewinnen sie auch nur 2-1. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die jetzt Lecce weggeschossen hätten. Aber du hast gemerkt, vor allen Dingen in de Bruyne, man merkt echt, es war ja auch ganz ruhig um ihn geworden. Er hat sich ja lange in Belgien auch behandeln lassen. Also er hatte ja diese schwere Muskelverletzung, war dann auch wochenlang gar nicht in Neapel. Da gab es dann auch immer mal so ein paar Fragen. Wann kommt der wieder? Wie schaut denn das aus? Und dann ist es relativ ruhig. Plötzlich hieß es im Februar, de Bruyne ist wieder in Neapel. Und dann kam er jetzt auch bald wieder in den Rhythmus. Und du hast jetzt gesehen, wie gesagt, es ist halt was anderes, wenn de Bruyne die Passfenster, die dir in de Bruyne öffnet, die Passlinien, ist halt was anderes. Dann kommt dieser Mcdominy dazu, der ja Napoli eh schon seit eineinhalb Jahren trägt. Also im Prinzip ist es schon, man kann Fußball wahnsinnig viel besprechen. Aber viel macht dann halt schon die Spielerqualität aus. Und das sieht man jetzt halt bei Napoli wirklich geballt, weil eben so viele so wichtige Spieler jetzt plötzlich gleichzeitig zurückkommen. Angizaya auch. Angizay ist für das Spiel dieser Napolimannschaft ja schon seit Skudetto-Zeiten, seit Spalletti enorm wichtig. Der war halt auch drei bis vier Monate raus. Und ja, jetzt hast du die halt wieder. Ja, dann schaut der Schnack schon anders aus.
Dann schaut der Schnack anders aus. Also, bei Napoli werden jetzt auch wieder die kleinsten Passfenster getroffen. Wenn du magst, dann schließt sich jetzt dein Podcastfenster. Christian, du hast noch andere Dinge zu tun. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du dir trotzdem Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, danke euch. Sorry, dass ich früher weg muss und viel Spaß noch.
Entspann dich, ne? Bis bald.
Gut, also, ciao, ciao.
Und wir blicken nochmal nach Spanien. Mensch, Fabian, jetzt musstest du eine ganze Weile hier warten. Aber ich habe eine Anekdote, mit der ich dein neues Thema einleiten kann. Wusstest du eigentlich, dass ich mal Martin de Mekeles fast zum FC Bayern gebracht hätte? Ich werde es nicht in allen Details jetzt auserzählen können hier, aber es begab sich zu der Zeit, als der FC Bayern mal wieder einen Trainer suchte. Ich glaube, es war nach Nagelsmann. Ach, als Trainer.
Ich dachte, als Spieler.
Nein, nein, nein, als Trainer. Dann saß ich in der Arena und habe mit einem Kollegen– Namen werden hier nicht genannt– gesagt, jetzt sind sie so verzweifelt, bald werden sie de Mekeles holen, einfach nur weil er gerade Erfolg in Südamerika hat, auch wenn keiner weiß, wie er spielen lässt. Ich kenne inzwischen auch, wie sich die Flüsterpost weiterentwickelt hat. Am Ende der Flüsterpost stand auf jeden Fall eine Sky90-Sendung, in der ein anwesender Journalist gesagt hat, wie wäre es denn mit Martin de Mekeles und Lothar Matthäus dann darauf reagieren musste. Du hast gesehen, er hat, wie wir alle, nichts von Martin de Mekeles Fußball gesehen. Er hat dann nur Dinge gesagt wie, er ist natürlich ein etablierter Spieler, er kennt den FC Bayern gut, spielt seinen eigenen Fußball, könnte eine Option sein. Dann war Martin de Mekeles auf einmal mal für 2-3 Tage ein Thema, bis dann E-Ball, glaube ich, gesagt hat. Ja, Leute, der ist es nicht. Aber jetzt endlich hat es Martin de Mekeles geschafft, er ist im europäischen Fußball gelandet, und zwar in Spanien.
In Spanien, genau, bei Real Mallorca ist er gelandet. Er war ja, habe ich ja völlig falsch geschrieben dir, er war ja schon in Europa, er hatte schon bei Bayern die zweite Mannschaft trainiert und die U19. Also es ist jetzt seine erste Profi-Station, muss man ja so sagen. Und ganz kurz vielleicht noch zu deiner Anekdote, als er beim FC Malaga damals gespielt hat, in unserer wahnsinnigen Scheichphase, hatte ich die Chance, mit ihm auch privat ein Interview zu führen, ein längeres, und konnte ihn dann ein bisschen über Fußball ausfragen und war sehr, sehr positiv überrascht, was er alles zu berichten hatte. Hat ihn auch nicht so wissens, ja wie soll ich sagen, nicht so eingeschätzt. Also hat mich da wirklich fasziniert, was er über Fußball erzählt hat, was er über die Spielweise erzählt hat, was er über Bayern erzählt hat, was er über Malaga erzählt hat, wie sie spielen, was er so erlebt hat. Und man hat schon rausgehört, dass der deutlich mehr kann, als nur den Innenverteidiger Gautschütter die Bälle wegschlägt, sondern Martin Demetelis. Würd ich auf der Liste weiter beobachten. Ich glaube, das kann schon noch eine interessante Trainerfigur werden. Und jetzt hat es ja geklappt mit seiner ersten Traineranstellung in Spanien. Da ist er ja auch sehr gerne und hat diesen Job jetzt bei Real Mallorca angenommen, der gar nicht so leicht ist. Denn er hat die, er muss Mallorca vor dem Abstieg retten und hat eigentlich nur einen Vertrag bis Ende der Saison. Das heißt, es ist auch so, wenn er es nicht schafft, dann hat er sich vielleicht auch schon viel verbaut wieder hier. Dementsprechend geht er auch ein bisschen ins Risiko. Er hat aber ganz ordentlich begonnen, hat in seinen ersten zwei Spielen vier Punkte geholt. Das erste Spiel hätte er eigentlich gewinnen müssen. Da waren sie 0-2 vorne bei Osasuna, haben dann in den letzten Minuten des Spiels, 89. und 94., noch zwei Tore bekommen, sodass es 2 zu 2 ausging. War aber, wie gesagt, dort schon sehr nahe am ersten Sieg. Das hat jetzt am letzten Wochenende geklappt. Es war gegen Espanol Barcelona mit 2 zu 1. Espanol ist oben mit dabei, es war also kein einfacher Gegner. Man muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, Espanol hat in diesem Spiel wahrscheinlich mehr verdient. Sie haben ein sehr strittiges 1 zu 1 bekommen. Espanol war 0-1 vorne. Das 1 zu 1 von Mallorca, wahrscheinlich ein Foulspiel vorangegangen, das der Schiri nicht geahndet hat, der auch nicht zum Waag rufen wurde, um sich das anzuschauen. Spanien-Schiedsrichter-Wesen ist nach wie vor Katastrophe. Liga sind wahnsinnig schlecht.
Es kann nicht sein, deutsche Schiedsrichter sind die Schlechtesten. Das kann ich sein, Fabian.
Also, deutsche Schiedsrichter würde ich mit Kuss an dir nehmen. Also wirklich. Und sogar die aus der 2. Liga. Also wirklich Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn, was hier passiert. In Spanien gibt es ja nach wie vor die Regel, wenn du als Schiedsrichter zweimal vom Waag rausgerufen wirst, bist du erstmal für ein Spiel gesperrt. Das heißt, die Schiedsrichter wollen sich auch gar nicht vom Waag beeinflussen lassen und bestehen dann auf ihre teilweise eben auch Fehlentscheidungen. Und in dem Fall war es eins. Für Martin Dimitjelis war es super, denn es war der Ausgleich. Und Mallorca hat dann das Spiel auch in der Schlussphase noch gedreht, mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen und hat sich jetzt ein klein bisschen Luft verschafft. Im Abstiegskampf ist, glaube ich, jetzt zwei Punkte vor den Abstiegszonen. Ist nach wie vor natürlich alles brandgefährlich. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde es eine sehr, sehr interessante Personalie. Ich wünsche ihm persönlich sehr, sehr viel Glück. Im Moment geht es um Abstiegskampf. Das heißt, spielerisch, was können wir groß berichten? Er hat die Mannschaft mehr zusammengeführt. Das Zentrum wird dichtgemacht. Es sind vier Mittelfeldspieler da. Er setzt auf eine Zehn, die im Moment Pablo Torre macht. Der ist vom FC Barcelona ausgelehnt. Er hat noch einen anderen Zehner, Sergi Dader. Der ist im Moment meistens von der Bank. Der ist auch beim FC Malaga groß geworden, war mal kurz vorm Nationalspieler. Er hat vorne mit Werdat Muriki aus Albanien einen tollen Stürmer, der nach wie vor für die wichtigen Tore sorgt. Aber es ist im Moment alles darauf ausgerichtet, erst mal hinten dicht zu stehen, aus dem Zentrum dann nach vorne zu spielen. Im Moment hat er jetzt, wie gesagt, vier Punkte geholt. Mallorca ist wieder ganz gut auf ihn zu sprechen. Es wird schon diskutiert, ob er einen Vertrag jetzt schon bekommen soll. Aber gut, es wird noch ein bisschen dauern. Mallorca, vielleicht noch ganz interessant, ist im Besitz dreier Amerikaner und zwar dreier amerikanischen Ex-Sportler. Andy Kohlberg ist Eigentümer und Präsident. Das war mal ein Tennisspieler. Steve Nash und Steve Kerr kennen wir vielleicht noch, die Namen aus der NBA. Und das sind die Eigentümer von Mallorca. Die haben auch vor ein paar Jahren Neustarling gebaut und haben auf jeden Fall eher die Absichten, nach oben zu gehen. Und hatten das in den letzten Jahren auch immer stückweise so ein bisschen geschafft, in der Liga sich nach oben zu arbeiten. Dieses Jahr hat es aber nicht so gut ausgesehen. Und jetzt muss eben Demicelis Mallorca erstmal retten und dann nächstes Jahr vielleicht was aufbauen.
Das wäre wirklich was. Und also aus dem Persönlichen höre ich nur die besten Geschichten. Jetzt von dir über Martin Demicelis. Ole Zeissler hat auch, als er mal seinen Derby-Film gemacht hat, auch nur in höchsten Tönen von ihm gesprochen und noch so über zwei, drei andere Ecken auch sehr, sehr schöne, sehr, sehr gute Geschichten. Also es scheint jemand zu sein, der sehr zugänglich ist.
Ich würde es ihm auf jeden Fall wünschen, dass es jetzt erst mal klappt mit dem Nichtabstieg, weil wie gesagt, wenn er jetzt das nicht schaffen sollte, dann wird es natürlich in Europa schwer. Wenn er es schafft, dann hat er sich eine Bühne aufbereitet. Und wie gesagt, in Spanien hat er einen guten Namen, in Deutschland glaube ich auch. Wird ein interessanter Trainer, ist 45 Jahre, da werden wir noch ein bisschen was von hören. Hoffentlich.
Ich möchte diese Folge hier mit Big Easy Muck widmen. If you know, you know. Dann lass uns noch dein zweites kurzes Thema annehmen. Wir haben mitbekommen oder vielleicht haben sie höheren oder höheren mitbekommen, Barca hat einen neuen alten Präsidenten und der ist ja auch Riesenfan von Hansi Flick. Und das ist für Hansi Flick, der ja auch sehr erfolgreich gerade ist, sicherlich nichts schlechtes.
Genau. Er soll auch seinen Vertrag verlängern. Er hat, glaube ich, bis 2027 Vertrag. Der soll noch mal ein Jahr herausgezogen, würde ich schon sagen, also verlängert werden. Er macht einen guten Job bei Barcelona nach wie vor, Hansi Flick. Er fühlt sich dort pudelwohl. Er hat auch gesagt, das möchte er. Es soll seine letzte Trainerstation sein. Und Laporta, du hast es gerade angesprochen, der Präsident hat vor ein paar Tagen die Präsidentschaftswahl gewonnen, hat diese gefeiert wie ein Rapstar. Weiß ich nicht, wie ich das ausdrücken soll. War wirklich unfassbar, was dafür zu sehen ist. Also dann noch um 3 Uhr in einem Club mit allen zusammen. Und die Spieler sind zur Wahl gekommen. Die hat er dann extra hingeführt und geshakert. Und er ist absolut da.
Der Außermarkt André Tastegen, der durfte nicht wählen.
Der durfte nicht wählen, ihr habt es mitbekommen in Deutschland, okay. Bei Laporta ist es dann immer so, Leute, die irgendwie vielleicht was gegen ihn haben könnten, die dürfen dann verschiedene Sachen machen.
Ja, Moment mal, also man muss das kurz erklären. Also jeder, der spielt bei Barca, der wird automatisch Barca-Mitglied. Und nur Barca-Mitglieder dürfen logischerweise den Präsidenten wählen. Und Marc-André Tastegen ist sogar zur Wahl erschienen. Aber es hieß, dass er in der Mitgliederliste nicht mehr verzeichnet ist. Oder wie ist das so richtig wiedergegeben?
Ja, so ungefähr. Also ganz genau habe ich dann auch nicht mehr verfolgt. Aber ich habe ihn nur gesehen, wie er da an dieser Wahlurne stand und eigentlich schon wählen wollte. Und sein Name taucht auf keiner Liste auf.
Er wird einfach bis zuletzt unwürdig behandelt. Der arme Marc-André, ey, das ist wirklich… Kommt zurück zu Gladbach, da wissen Sie das nicht.
Es ist nicht seine Saison, es ist nicht seine Saison, kann man leider so sagen.
Das wird jetzt passieren, das ist klar, wie bei David Chiles damals.
Ja, das stimmt, genau.
Gladbach bei Sky 90 am Sonntag.
Ich habe es zu öffentlich gesagt. Niemand würde sich öffentlich auf den Rasenfunk beziehen wollen. Aber die sehr direkte Flüsterpost, die damals in Gang gesetzt wurde, einfach nur von einem… Die war schon lustig. Aber gut, das kann ich euch auf einmal nochmal erzählen, wie das genau lief dann.
Naja, aber auf jeden Fall ist es so, La Porta ist nach wie vor im Amt. Das neue Stadion ist jetzt wirklich voll einsatzfähig und Barca läuft es gut. Mit Hansi Flick, wie gesagt, hat er alles auf eine Karte gesetzt, damals La Porta. Das war ja kein unumstrittener Transfer. Er hätte auch schön in die andere Richtung gehen können. Aber es passt im Moment einfach zwischen Flick, Barca und den Spielern natürlich. Und auch in der Liga und in der Champions League sind sie gut dabei. Haben auch ganz keinen, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, eine super saubere Saison hinter sich. Viele Verletzungs-Sorgen auch gehabt. La Minia mal immer wieder mit Leistenproblemen. Rafinha hatte mal ein kleines Loch, Lewandowski war mal verletzt. Aber sie kompensieren das gut. Sie haben natürlich aus der eigenen Jugend nach wie vor einen unsagbar großen Fundus an Nachwuchsspielern, die dann kommen können, wenn es irgendwie brennt. Und Flick managt das gut und fühlt sich, wie gesagt, wohl in Barcelona und wird wahrscheinlich jetzt die nächsten Tage bis 28 nochmal verlängern. Und schauen wir mal, was Barcelona dann dieses Jahr noch an Titeln erreicht. Einen haben sie ja nicht mehr oder können sie nicht mehr reichen. Das ist der Copa del Rey, das sind sehr geben. Atletico Madrid ausgeschieden und das ist ja auch jetzt das kommende Champions League Duell, wird also nicht ganz unspannend. Ich glaube vor allen Dingen Basa tut sich dann gegen solche Teams wie Atletico deutlich schwerer als vielleicht irgendwelche internationalen Teams. Deswegen glaube ich, wird das doch deutlich enger, als man es vielleicht im Moment vermutet.
Ja, das war ja das mit dem Hinspiel 4 zu 0 bei Atletico und dann im Rückspiel 3 zu 0 für Basa. Ob ihm das noch mal passiert, so ein Hinspiel, wobei diesmal ist die Konstellation ja eine andere, also anders herum. Ah ja, da kann man wirklich sehr gespannt drauf sein. Mensch, ihr jetzt nur noch zwei. Das hat mal wieder Spaß gemacht, mit euch über den europäischen Fußball zu sprechen. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Danke dir, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast.
Sehr gerne. Hat mir Spaß gemacht, wie immer.
Sollte es irgendjemanden noch nicht mitbekommen haben, es gibt ein Tribüngespräch zu eurem Buch, das erschienen ist. Hoffentlich haben die TV im Himmel, ist natürlich in den Show Notes verlinkt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Definitiv kann man sich bestellen, am besten in der örtlichen Buchhandlung. Vielleicht nicht bei dem großen Versand, der einem als ersten einfällt. Aus Gründen, aus vielerlei Gründen, muss man sagen. Also danke dir, lieber Uli, und danke, lieber Fabian. Du musst noch ein Buch schreiben, damit ich das hier in die Kamera halten kann. Aber ich würde das definitiv lesen.
Es wird ein Buch über den FC Malaga. Du wirst das irgendwann noch mitbekommen. Es ist unwahrscheinlich spannend, was hier passiert. Vielleicht steigen wir dieses Jahr tatsächlich wieder in die 1. Liga auf. Und dann wird es nächstes Jahr im Rasenfunk aber richtig rund gehen.
Und wenn dann der Titel nicht der Malaga-Bächer ist, dann verstehe ich die Welt nicht mehr.
Ja, das kriegen wir hin. Also danke dir, lieber Fabian. Und in Abwesenheit natürlich auch nochmal danke an Christian Bernhard. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist von euch finanziert. Wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt, das erfahrt ihr, wenn ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht und dann auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt. Außerdem ist auch eine Video unter der Podcast-Beschreibung alles nochmal verlinkt. Geht via PayPal oder andere Wege ja inzwischen sehr, sehr schnell. Wir haben auch so einen QR-Code, den man einfach nur abscannen muss auf der Webseite. Dann könntet ihr einen Dauerauftrag einrichten, wenn ihr das möchtet. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei CK3, bei Sigofa, bei Julia, bei Dimitri und bei Andreas K. Sie alle haben uns in der Vergangenheit unterstützt. Vielen herzlichen Dank dafür. Feedback zu dieser Folge sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Und ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr dem Rasenfunk gewogen bleibt. Und abonniert auch sehr gerne mal das Tribügengespräch, denn zum einen gibt es da die Sendung eben mit den beiden Hebes. Und da wird es auch was geben, was ich heute schon mal so ein bisschen so indirekt angeteased habe. Kommt dann nächste Woche. Bleibt oder werdet gesund. Macht's gut. Ciao!